a witness has come forward and said that
Daniel Penny the subway Samaritan is a
hero because they were all terrified for
their lives until he intervened to save
them and I think this context is
important they're saying the charges
should be dropped it's particularly
important because the New York Times is
arguing that the passenger passengers
should have intervened to stop Daniel
Penny to protect the man who was
victimizing them and in fact they say
several protesters are demanding the
incarceration and uh insisting on the
culpability of the passengers as
perpetrators saying that because they
did not do anything to stop this they
were guilty
so not only are they outright saying if
you defend yourself you go to jail
they're saying if you cower in fear as
someone else defends themselves they're
going to lock you up too
we got that plus another Amazing Story
out of New York you may have seen this
because the video got 40 million views
over the weekend a hospital worker
accused of being a racist Karen who was
trying to steal a city bike which is one
of those bike rental bike sharing things
from a young black teenager the only
problem is it turns out she had a
receipt for the bike and the real story
is this white Hospital worker who was
six months pregnant was having her bike
stolen by a group of young black
teenagers that seems to be the case
considering the evidence presented and
published showing she actually had the
receipt for the bike and they were
trying to take it from her yet Ben Crump
and all of his activists came out and
said that she was a racist caring well
her uncle has launched a GoFundMe to
support her so we're going to talk a lot
about self-defense and criminal justice
because we also have Sam Britton
remember that guy who was stealing all
the luggage he has been arrested as a
fugitive from Justice from the Biden
Administration to jail so we got a lot
to go over but before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com click
the link in the description below and
join the cast Brew Coffee Club and you
will get three bags of our signature
cast brew coffee
uh supporting Casper coffee it's our
company we're sponsoring ourselves if
you like the work we do and you like
coffee then buy from us we've got Keurig
cups K-cups or whatever I don't know
what you're supposed to call them maybe
not supposed to say Keurig or something
K-Cups they call them that will be
rolling out in the next couple of weeks
so I'll I'll say this if you guys have a
coffee shop if you have a convenience
store if you buy coffee for your office
buy from us and support companies that
don't hate you because we are using this
these resources we are using the funds
from Casper to launch coffee shops the
first one's currently under construction
a lot of work has to be done in building
a cafe but we want to set up these
cultural hubs all over the country in
cities everywhere so that people can
come in for coffee and they can bask in
culture that is good watching on our TV
screens in our cafes shows like Crowder
and Tim cast and Viva and Barnes and
things like that so again casper.com but
don't forget to head over to timcast.com
and click join us to become a member and
you'll get access to uncensored members
only shows we're going to have one for
you tonight at about 10 10 p.m on the
front page of timcast.com and as a
member if you've been a member for at
least six months or you sign up at the
25 level you can submit questions and
even call into the show so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is Colby Covington
thanks Tim for having me it's an honor
man my my mom's a big fan she subscribed
to your channel years ago so you know
she besides the fact that you're
incredibly smart and an intellectual you
know she's a huge fan of your coffee so
she's right here always ordering your
coffee yeah I'm sure if I could get some
coffee today it would make her dreams
come true I appreciate it thank you so
much and uh everybody knows who you are
but you want to give a brief
introduction okay so uh you know I'm a
UFC fighter you know you a UFC champion
uh Donald Trump's favorite fighter the
people's Champion America's Champion the
king of Miami so I got a lot of titles
that I've won in my days fighting in the
UFC and you know now I'm a full-time
Patriot fighting for the conservative uh
movement right on man thanks for hanging
out we're honored to have you it's honor
to be here thank you right on we got
Sheamus hanging out my name is Seamus
Coughlin I make cartoons at a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we just
uploaded one today on the fact that men
get periods now so if you guys want to
go over there check that out I think
you'll enjoy it
how you doing everybody I am uh
phillibanti I'm the lead singer of All
That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary
Ian's missing yeah he's just gone so
literally we're looking for him everyone
I've literally checked everywhere in the
house yeah yeah he's probably just
leaving yeah have you asked have you
looked in his room
well that's an invasion of his privacy
I'm not saying it's a good point yeah I
don't want to knock in case he's napping
or something that's that's fair
uh that'd be a really long nap but uh
I'm surge.com I'm ready to start
whenever you guys are so all right let's
jump into this first story we have this
from Fox News witness to Jordan nearly
Chokehold death calls Daniel penny a
hero NYC passenger says Marine vet cared
for people and that is his crime uh the
funny thing is that's literally a crime
these days caring for others in New York
City especially they say a retiree who
witnessed the Fatal choking incident
call Daniel penny a hero and slammed
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg for
prosecuting him he's a Heroes of the
passenger the witness who described
herself as a woman of color said it was
wrong for brag to charge Penny it was
self-defense and I believe in my heart
that he saved a lot of people that day
that could have gotten hurt you know I
want to I want to point point out too
when we look at this video and we hear
the story of uh of Jordan Neely
threatening to hurt people I I don't
know about you guys but I kind of feel
like I'm probably underestimating how
serious it was like it's not just some
guy threatening people I'm willing to
bet it's more serious than anybody
believes like he was getting up in
someone's face or coming at somebody or
or doing like a Flinch you know it's
like take like a like a faint shot at
him to try and get him you know
something is more than just him yelling
well yeah I mean because people on the
subway are thanking him there's footage
of people thinking him after it occurred
I haven't seen anything about anyone who
is on that train car coming out and
saying he went too far and shouldn't
have done this I've heard nothing at all
about nothing and from anyone that was
on the train car actually complained
nobody has said anything negative and
I'm a hero yeah I mean I can't imagine
why there would be protesters saying
that the people that were on the train
that didn't stop
the Marine I forget his name the Marine
from from Penny Penny from from
restraining Jordan
like they're asking they're they're
saying that the other people should be
punished for not doing what they're
literally punishing penny for right now
well this is hilarious right because
here's what would happen if they could
go back in time if they had a time
machine they go back in time and then
they stop him from putting the
assailants in a choke hold and then
everyone gets charged for not stopping
them from putting him in a Chokehold or
putting him in a Chokehold and then
handling it's just a chain of everyone
putting him in a Chokehold and never
going into jail for putting him in each
other New York is finished Colby have
you have you seen the video about what
happened with this Marine I haven't seen
the video but I've I've heard uh some of
the reports about it and you know it's
disgusting it you know Daniel penny is a
hero he's a good Samaritan obviously
everybody on the train felt threatened
by by that Jordan Neely so I mean look
at Jordan Neely's pass I mean isn't he
didn't he like rape a kid or like kidnap
something yeah like he's a screaming
Time Felon he was arrested several times
he punched an old man and an old woman
in the face in different occasions he
was arrested like was it like 40 times
or something but I'm curious I I guess
I'm trying to ask you because I think
out of anybody in the room you're the
only one who has any expertise in
fighting yeah and I'm wondering I don't
know like is there concern
for for you knowing how to actually
fight I guess the argument we've heard
from the left is
it what Jordan nearly did didn't warrant
choking him to death and my response was
I don't think Penny was trying to choke
him to death I think he was trying to
stop him so I guess I don't know enough
about fighting to know where that line
is or what what you think about what is
acceptable in terms of subduing somebody
yeah you know he was obviously trying to
subdue him and there's no way anybody
could have thought he was going to kill
him by just you know removing his
conscious you know by choking him out it
happens in the UFC all the time guys get
real naked choke they go to sleep and
then they wake up so there must be some
type of cause in in the Jordan Neely
that caused that death you know I don't
think it was just by natural causes from
a Choco I think there's some
extracurricular activity going on maybe
he was doing drugs maybe some other
things that's actually what a lot of
people think yeah because he he
afterwards uh Penny puts him in the
recovery position and the other
passengers and then he was still moving
and breathing and then they bring him to
the hospital and he died I guess it was
like on the way there or something yeah
well I mean regardless this guy was
acting in defense of the other people on
the train he didn't he didn't just go
out of his way to choke this dude out
for no reason yeah I mean look no matter
what how people wanted to spin the
interaction the like Jordan was being
restrained like Perry wasn't
aggressively attacking him that's not
what anyone saw they looked at the if
you look at the video Jordan they were
trying to restrain Jordan trying to hold
his hands trying to prevent him from
hurting someone else they weren't on him
smashing his head exactly they were
beating him that wasn't an aggressive
fight that was trying to prevent him
from being aggressive against other
people you obviously you know what it
looks like when someone's aggressively
trying to punch someone you know it
doesn't look like he was trying to hurt
him that's what I'm saying this guy was
a marine if he wanted to just savagely
beat this guy to death it would have
looked very different it would have
looked very different check this out so
the witness the witness account from
this woman she's in her 60s said I'm
sitting on the train reading my book and
all of a sudden I hear someone spewing
this rhetoric he said I don't care if I
have to kill an F I will I will I will
go to jail I'll take a bullet recall the
woman who's in her 60s the terrified
passengers crowded towards the exit
doors I'm looking at where we are in the
tube in the Sardine Can and I'm like
okay we're between stations there's
nowhere we can go the people on the
train we were scared we were scared for
our lives Penny's stepped in when nearly
studies in the world kill and bullet why
in the world would you take a bullet why
you don't take a bullet because you
snatch something from somebody's hand
you take it for violence the witness
said it was clear to her that Penny wait
until the last minute to intervene for
the sake of his fellow passengers shared
a thump when he dragged nearly to the
ground but couldn't clearly see until
the doors opened at the Broadway
Lafayette station and most of the
passengers exited the witness waited for
police to arrive to provide a statement
Mr Penny cared for people that's what he
did that is his crime she told Fox News
digital after the altercation she and at
least three other passengers thanked him
damn that's amazing nobody wants to kill
anybody Mr Penny didn't want to kill
that man you should have seen the way Mr
Penny looked he was distraught he was
very very visibly distressed and he
didn't go he didn't run he stayed
prosecutor Joshua steinglass said at
Penny's arraignment Friday that the
Marine veteran who has lived his entire
life in the New York area continued to
hold nearly for a period of time after
the man had stopped moving I don't think
that's true I think in the video you can
see the dude is still waving his arms
around and there's other men trying to
stop him so something else was going on
than just this
they say it took three men to hold Mr
Neely down he was struggling after
widespread protester across the city
with many demonstrators even politicians
calling penny a murderer brag charged
Penny and now I'm hearing that they're
they're like regular New Yorkers saying
criminal charges should not be coming
from a tiny Fringe group of people
that's something I mean I obviously we
can't verify whether or not the people
that have been protesting are actually
New Yorkers or not but it wouldn't
surprise me considering the history of
protests you know the past five or so
years in the US that these people were
from out of state making a stink in a in
the subway when your average New Yorker
is probably like please don't charge
this guy because we all hate dealing
with mentally unstable people on in the
Subway because they are there are
mentally unstable people they they do
need help the the city needs to do
something about it but at the end of the
day it's the average New Yorker that
pays the price you know it's like
they're the ones that that get
terrorized when they're on the subway
and stuff so I just know I don't see how
the average person in New York City is
like oh you know we need to punish this
guy there's more uh the guy who filmed
it said he started screaming he said he
had no food no drink that he was tired
doesn't care if he goes to jail he
started screaming all these things and
took off his jacket a blackjack that he
hadn't threw in on the ground The
Narrative that has emerged has become
about race a white man who fatally
choked a black man the witness said this
isn't about race this is about people of
all colors who are very very afraid and
a man who stepped in to help them so so
here's the picture being painted by the
witnesses they're cowering in the back
of the truck as this guy screaming takes
his jacket off throws it on the ground
and only at that point when he sang he's
about to kill people or he's going to
and he takes his jacket off
like it looks like he's about to engage
dude these men decide to subdue him they
it it sounds like he had all the things
that or he had exhibited all the things
that necessary for legitimate
self-defense you know he's there so he's
got his fist he's making threats you
know listen to this the the woman she
said I miss the city under the law and
order of Giuliani when it comes to
exposing people are subjecting them to
Violent Behavior the people who are in
power are supposed to protect us are not
that's a that's amazing wow it's
completely correct right these people
they actively work against Civil Society
it's not just the case that you don't
get in trouble for breaking the law you
do get in trouble for stopping somebody
from breaking the law yeah 100 and so
this is what the media has made
perfectly clear to the American people
over the past several years and this is
something they've believed for decades
but they've gotten explicitly clear in
their messaging about this we saw this
during the 2020 riots right 30 people
died the vast majority of people don't
know any of their names but everyone
knows Kyle rittenhouse's name do you
know why because he defended himself he
didn't let the mob murder him and that's
not what he was supposed to do he was
supposed to allow himself to be killed
and he didn't which is why he needs to
be charged because he's setting an
example for people he's showing people
that you don't have to roll over and die
because mob is rioting in your
neighborhood or a neighborhood that
you're invested in protecting
there was a there's another name that
everybody remembers do you know what it
is
one other one other person
uh uh catching David Dorner David Dorney
David Norton yeah do you know why they
remember his name he died right he was a
police officer and he was trying to
protect a business that was being looted
when they shot him over a TV and people
they remember his name you're the you
they I don't know for For Better or For
Worse if you try and defend yourself
people are gonna remember who you are
the left for bad reasons and the right
for good reasons
do you remember the name of the woman
who was pushed in front of the train and
murdered let me write her name on the
show I can't remember either nope nobody
cares well no one's gonna talk about
that right that's crazy because that's
business as usual but citizens standing
up for themselves against criminals is
not and that's not supposed to happen
you guys ready for this one
here we go from The New York Times they
watched Jordan Neely die did they have a
duty to intervene oh interesting are you
supposed to intervene
crazy when there's a threat are you
supposed to step in and do something
yeah insane and wild I feel like this is
intentionally to make people lose their
minds it's like how is it that they're
gonna go ahead and argue for people to
intervene on Jordan Neely's behalf when
the other guy was intervening on
everyone in the Subway's behalf unreal
it's unbelievable you ready you ready
for this please oh my goodness arrest
everyone that was on that train read one
protester sign love and protect your
fellow man don't move here if you're
scared of your neighbors which it also
added if you watch someone choke and
attack and kill another you are
complicit you are responsible also I
just want to make a point that sign that
says don't move here if you're scared of
your neighbors of course not because if
you're scared of your neighbors you're
already in New York see this is the
thing I wouldn't doesn't isn't there a
part of all of you that wants everyone
on that train to be arrested no why not
no no because the people of New York
learn a lesson about who they voted for
and maybe then no no okay okay you're
right you're right the people of New
York will never learn a lesson about it
forever that's not true and that's why I
say you're right because the witness the
woman who called Penny hero says she
wants Giuliani back yeah like maybe
there is a lesson being learned by
people that they might stop voting for
this I can be hopeful I will I kind of
have doubt no one does a better job
creating demand for Republicans than
Democrats yeah I I can't imagine how
people are gonna continue to allow this
kind of stuff to happen as more and more
victims are created like people every
day are dealing with this kind of stuff
on on the subway and I can't imagine
again I just can't imagine the the
people of New York actually supporting
it it's got to be activists that are
that are making no noise yeah well and
it's about a you know the stories the
media chooses to focus on so as we were
discussing what an innocent person is
pushed in front of a train by a complete
Maniac that's not a story that's
discussed and then when a citizen
intervenes to prevent somebody who is a
career criminal who's behaving violently
screaming about the fact that they're
not afraid to go back to jail and
they'll kill somebody not only is there
even a question in anyone's mind about
whether this was an appropriate instance
for this person intervening but we're
seeing pictures of the person who died
moonwalking in a subway station is if
that absolves him I just just think this
this whole New York Times article is
Magic it is it's hilarious absolute
magic it's like an onion article dude
right should they have a duty to
intervene what do you think Daniel Penny
was doing he was stopping a violent man
who was threatening people he was
literally intervening now in their world
you're like at a bank and some guy
breaks in to rob that bank and the
security guard aims a weapon at the
burglar at the bank robber and the New
York Times wants you to intervene to
help the bank robbery that's what
they're arguing for and that's the thing
this this isn't just beyond parody right
this isn't just a joke this is actually
a clever joke right like if the onion or
the Babylon B published that headline
I'd be like all right that's a good
angle because it shows the hypocrisy and
it's also funny and it's ridiculous this
was the New York Times being completely
unironic I'm I'm I'm often very worried
for for Seth over the Babylon B because
yeah I mean what is he supposed to
publish I know look what about me I make
cartoons about this stuff this is a
cartoon this is actually a cartoon like
I do more comedy than you do at this
point by simply no reading headlines
just reading the news it's true it's
really getting to that point I know but
it's terrifying comedy it's like people
are like are you worried that ai's gonna
be able to generate comedy I'm like the
New York Times already does you can't
compete dude yeah wow when I saw this
headline I was really impressed
because as you pointed out it creates a
paradox of intervention yeah exactly
they're like penny intervenes so then
someone intervenes to stop penny so then
someone intervenes to stop that person
and then everyone in the train is
fighting each other under some legal
requirement exactly and then the next
article is like should the people at the
subway stop have intervened and stopped
everyone on the subway car from stopping
the people in the subway car they were
stopping for about three weeks there
would be no one left in Manhattan
exactly everybody's dead everyone
everyone's just choking each other yeah
they're all it's like a human centipede
of of tokens
my gosh
so so where are we on this whole
self-defense thing right
not New York thankfully the left doesn't
want like we've talked about you know
the left does want to take away your
right to self-defense because they don't
believe that you should defend yourself
against people that have already been
victimized by Society I've said this
before the left believes that the people
that like Jordan himself was a victim he
had been victimized all his life he was
a victim of circumstance victim of a
system etc etc so when you have someone
that's victimized like that and he's
just acting out in this terrible world
that he's been oppressed in and then the
white man comes and kills him and that's
the way that's the entirety of the left
you know outlook on it and so the the
white guy has come and victimized the
black guy at the end of the day and they
can't abide by the idea that he was
victimized again by historically
powerful people Etc and and it's it's a
simple concept to understand but it
takes all the agency away from every
single person that behaves in a bad way
and it makes excuses for them and you
can't have a society that doesn't have a
standard that is your life is your own
and you can defend it if you have if you
can't defend your own life Society
breaks down exactly so so Jordan Neely
was screaming at innocent people after a
life of crime because of socioeconomic
factors because we didn't fund that
library because his Public School wasn't
good enough for on par with European
standards or standards and more wealthy
neighborhoods it's an imaginary standard
but Daniel Penny he just woke up and
wanted to kill a black person right
that's the only analysis we do on the
fact that somebody is dead on this train
right he just woke up one morning and
said I just I guess I just want to go
out and kill a black person that is
literally how the left sees the story
every single level of socioeconomic
analysis is done to exonerate Jordan
Neely but they're lying like they don't
literally believe that I just lie I
think so I think you're right that they
lie but there are True Believers on the
left who if you really press them or you
just try to infer from their conclusions
they really seem to believe that white
people are just searching for excuses to
kill black people all the time there are
people because every time there's an
instance where a white person defends
themselves against a black person it's
well oh look at that white guy killed a
black guy because he's racist really
that's the first that's the first
assumption weren't you saying something
earlier about your hands being deadly
weapons like is that like a law or
something yeah so that's a law when you
become a pro professional fighter you
have to register your hands with the
police no yes you had to go to the
police and tell them I mean you're
supposed to I never ended up doing it
because I knew I was never gonna break a
law like I handle my business in the
cage where we get paid a lot of money to
to fight people I would never assault
someone outside the cage so you know I I
I would never have to deal with that so
I heard that I heard that when I was
little they said that if you're if you
get like a black belt then like as a kid
they say it makes your hands deadly
weapons as an adult I was told it makes
uh assault aggravated like if you're a
trained fighter and you commit a crime
it's an aggravated crime as if a regular
person had a weapon and you being
trained aggravates it or something yeah
well I remember before the show you were
telling a story about somebody who was a
wrestler and got in some trouble yeah so
there was this wrestler in my in my
college of Oregon State and uh he uh got
in a fight at a party because the guy
was like cussing at his girlfriend so
he's like dude I'm not you're not gonna
cuss at my girlfriend then the guy like
pushed him and like threw a punch in my
Sucker Punch so he's like let's go
outside so he took it outside double
legs the guy on the ground the guy hits
his head off the concrete and had to get
stitches and then goes to the police and
ends up my friend ended up getting
assault with a deadly weapon because he
was a wrestler that's insane crazy ended
up having to do three and a half years
in prison no oh my gosh that's why I
always tell people like the fight's not
worth it yeah I mean like you're saying
fight in the fight in the cage make it
professional but I've heard too many
stories about people who they get
emotional yeah
and you know nine times out of out of 10
99 times out of 100 fights usually break
up someone gets a bruise nobody is kind
of the end of it
you get that one moment where someone
falls back and hits their head and you
and you go to prison yeah it's not worth
it man
it's tough though when the adrenaline
gets going like people don't know how to
control their adrenaline rushes like
it's a real thing like when you're in
that type of moment where it's like high
intensity and you feel like you know
you're about to get in a fight like the
adrenaline the nerves start getting to
you and you know you can't handle your
emotions you don't think clearly anymore
so you know I I kind of I feel for those
people I think I think more people
should probably do some kind of fight
training because even thinking about
situations like this with uh with Penny
he's a Marine he was probably cool as a
cucumber like everyone else is freaking
out he's probably thinking like all
right I got I got to stop this guy
before it gets out of hand and that's
why he was able to do it and then those
other guys help him do it but you get
someone who's terrified and shaking and
things can get a lot worse than than
they did here like in New York when you
get cops who are poorly trained and they
start unloading their their guns and
then this actually happened they ended
up shooting seven random people because
they were panicking and just like people
need to be able to be be in control that
was at the Empire State Building right
yeah yeah yeah did you guys hear that
story yeah no guy came out of the
building I guess he had it was like a
disgruntled shooting or something yeah
I'm not sure what it was but the police
unloaded and they shot him but I think
they missed him well I mean the thing is
they were using nine millimeters so they
may have missed him but they also may
have hit him and they just go pass
through because they're fast they hit
like seven random people just like
because they were just like ah we're
just shooting like terrified of this guy
and I mean it could have been you know
ricochets or whatever but still you know
yeah you're shooting guns in New York
City like just because you're cops
doesn't mean the bullets stopping the
bad guy or you know they don't bounce or
whatever so
um gotta be careful man yeah you guys
want to get can we just make everybody
really mad and we'll just keep going
with it sure yeah that's our job this is
it from Fox News North Dakota man who
killed an 18 year old boy following
critical argument has charges reduced oh
so this story is actually from a couple
weeks ago yeah but uh we overlooked it
and a lot of people are now picking the
story up you may remember this story
it's this guy Shannon Brandt he
apparently called the police called some
kid he claimed this this 18 year old kid
was a republican extremist and then ran
him over
they charged them with murder recently
they dropped it down to manslaughter and
they're saying it wasn't part of a plea
agreement meaning the prosecutors just
quietly were like we're going to reduce
his charges on this one yo it feels more
and more like across the country if you
if you like Donald Trump if you are a
conservative if you're libertarian if
you oppose the establishment they will
throw not just the book but any book
they have at you
there is unquestionably political
motivation against conservatives and
Libertarians people that are that are
generally anti-establishment there is a
strong strong incentive uh to do
everything you can to punish those
people for their opinions I don't think
that there's a there's gonna be people
that are going to say no that's not true
and stuff I really find it difficult to
see anything else and you got 20 the the
the riots in 2020 people like this guy
kill a kid dude he hit somebody with his
car after a political argument yeah
after a political argument that's like
that's an extremely important part this
is a politically motivated murder there
was that kid in uh how could that here's
the thing like to drop it to
manslaughter I mean how could it be
unintentional and they go out of your
way to hit somebody with a car and he
ran ran wow yeah this guy manslaughter
are you out of your mind he got into an
argument with someone and ran it threw
it over with his car I think the kids
were like dancing in the street or
something and he had known the kid and
he called him a republican extremist
ends up running the kid over uh they
said he fled the scene and they upgraded
the charges to felony murder probably
because he fled yeah and uh they said he
has also been charged with leaving the
scene of a crash that resulted in death
and now not because of plea agreement
they just said
as we have Point that's at the beginning
there's no evidence to support the
misplaced allegation of intentional
homicide the state and defense forensic
experts have provided a comprehensive
reports confirming that tragedy was an
accident misplaced media hype and
Community conjecture is no substitute
for evidence Mr brand is anxious for the
truth to be told to a jury trial Fair
Point Fair Point let's see let's see a
jury trial I'll say this innocent until
proven guilty extends to even people
like this and uh maybe it is media hype
but like when you charge him with
fleeing a crime you have to understand
why we feel that way so don't don't say
it's misplaced media hype when y'all
literally charge the guy with leaving
the scene of a crime that resulted in
death so like he says it's a republican
extremist runs him over it leaves and
then you're like as an accident
wow yeah I guess he's gonna argue that
he ran him over and thought it was a
rabbit well but that's the thing right
because there was a prior relationship
here they clearly didn't like each other
political argument there was no prior
relationship between Jordan Neely and
Daniel Penny he was threatening people
on the subway so he intervened right it
was just clearly situational this this
is a little a little different take on
it but listen if you're a conservative
or if you're a libertarian I know you
got a life and stuff but if you get put
onto a jury stay like get in there and
get on the jury and if it happens to be
someone that has political leanings that
align with you jury nullification is a
great tool look at this headline from uh
the original story man admits to running
over 18 year old after they had a
political argument
unbelievable
see he admitted he admitted to running
over the teenager
leaving the scene of a crime
after having a political argument and
they're like nice one
yo if you're a trump supporter and you
fart they're gonna lock you up yeah
they're gonna be like what was that I
smell something yeah well you smelt it
Delta Act of 1987. you know and this
isn't what this is in Montana was it or
Wyoming North Dakota North Dakota North
Dakota I mean it's it's not a typically
a Bastion of progressive liberalism
there you know I mean there are
definitely Democrats I would imagine
blue dog Democrats like the kid called
his mom said it was being chased like
this is premeditated this is this is
first degree yeah it's amazing they
called it felony murder I'm like this is
prima he's chasing the kid the kid calls
mom saying he's being chased we don't
have a justice system in the gun this
country anymore you know we talked about
it's drunk too this kid oh my gosh like
if you're if you're driving drunk and
you hit somebody you get charged with
like vehicular homicide negligent
homicide this is crazy whether it be the
whether it be the the stuff with George
Floyd or with the omen arbory case or
with this or it's like very frequently
there is significantly
you know significantly bad bad
prosecutions and stuff you know I mean
the FBI going after Trump with the the
stuff that came out with the Durham case
all that I I don't see how people can
continue to trust the justice system
when there are so many high profile
abuses of the you know of the justice
system it's it's it's detrimental to the
the country they want you to wear an
auntie for shirt
it's the only way you'll get you'll get
justice but then they want you promote
those ideas it's it's it's I'm half
kidding but it's kind of like how
businesses put up antifa stuff in their
Windows yeah I was in uh we were we were
out in the West Virginia area uh we're
working on the cafe and I see some of
these businesses having lgbtq plus
flyers in their windows and I'm like a
lot of these businesses probably don't
care someone comes in says okay put
something in the window say fine but
some of them especially in West Virginia
are like please don't hurt me you can
put whatever you want in the window
please spare our store that was like the
line from the 2020 riots please spare
our store because he's far left us are
going around and destroying every like
dude if you're a small business you
can't afford to replace your front
windows I'm talking thousands of dollars
this makes me wonder if this is like
what the french Terror was like how
intense were the the leftists in in the
French Revolution you know how intense
were they going after the population to
to terrorize them into agreeing I can't
imagine that it was you know
significantly more intense than at least
2020. well they were beheading people
uh that's true yeah a lot of people's
pretty bad and then turn on themselves
yeah yeah Rob spear was like oh no they
blew his jaw let that but let that be a
lesson to what's going to happen to
these people the revolution eats its own
children but Society was Society was
also significantly more violent back
then well look all I'm saying is don't
be surprised if they start killing
people we've already seen Terror attacks
from lefties on their eyes I mean and
they have literally said on television
we should kill them Jane Fonda said
murder is how we are going to solve the
problem yeah well she didn't she she
they asked her what could we do and she
says murder and then they all
immediately go no she's joking she's
joking and then she rolls her eyes
covering for her yeah like she only
joking man these people are nuts Hanoi
Jane yeah they're they're they're
getting crazy out there man so I kind of
feel like maybe this summer we'll see
some Shenanigans yeah but I think 2024
summer is going to get crazy I am
concerned about uh next year getting
into the uh the election
so I got to ask you
um during the coven riots in 2020 you
you've been I'm sorry not the cover
rights what's wrong with me kovid 2020
rides a lot happened that year it was a
great time it was all of US inflation
right yeah yeah it was a good time no I
wanted to ask uh as a a fighter when did
you start to get involved politically
yeah so I I started to get you know I've
always grew up conservative my whole
entire life but I really started to
really started to Branch out when I saw
that the media and all the athletes were
just shoving one way down your throat
the liberal way and I'm like why why is
no one else talking about conservative
beliefs and then I started to realize
like all these athletes like they don't
want to disrupt their gravy train
they're getting paid by these general
managers by these owners managers
whatever and if they say something
they're gonna be bagging you know
groceries at Walmart so I'm like you
know what I'm an independent contractor
for the UFC thank God for Dana White and
the UFC what they do letting us be uh
independent contractors we don't have to
get our voices muzzled we could say
whatever we want so you know my paycheck
is not affected by what I believe in and
what I stand for so you know that's when
I really started to come out I was just
sick of seeing the LeBron James way you
know it just you know defund the police
uh oh I care about equality and
Injustice and women's rights women's
rights bro LeBron you you abuse women
you got women in Chinese sweatshops
you're working for pennies on the dollar
you're making hundreds of Millions after
them how could you care about women's
rights when you're a woman abuser yeah
wow it's funny how you don't see these
people talk about creating real American
jobs no so that we can do away with
Sweatshop labor and help American
workers bring back Manufacturing
whatever whatever talking point the meet
the Democratic party or the media tells
them to say they just regurgitated it's
just virtue signal it's empty virtue
signaling oh it's nonsense so like what
kind of pressure has been put on I know
you said you're a private contractor but
have people sort of tried to step in the
way of that get clients in trouble get
the UFC in trouble absolutely so we had
a we had a Reebok was sponsor in the UFC
and they didn't sponsor me individually
they just sponsored the you know the
company they didn't sponsor me
individually after one of my fights they
tried to retract some of my statements
saying oh we don't stand for what Colby
Covington believes oh we're asking for
him to get fired from the UFC and Dana's
just like laughing like
it's an independent contractor can I ask
what you said or is this something you
can say on air or I just you know I just
you know after I beat this guy that was
all about uh black lives matter I just
you know I crushed his dreams and I just
you know stood up for conservatism and I
was patriotic and they didn't like the
way I said it but it's crazy how like
they can say whatever they want
politically oh yeah and there's nothing
and then you do the exact same thing
they did but for your beliefs and
they're like shut them down fire him I
do think it's awesome that Dana's
laughing and he's like no yeah that's
great because a lot of a lot of Major
League Sports they they have in their
contracts they'll go to the player the
athlete and be like you really gotta
tone it down you know like we're getting
we're getting heat I think people who
have Fu money need to start acting like
they got Fu money yeah what are they so
scared of it's the weirdest thing but
you know you know it might be it might
be that UFC is
I I think it's just a bunch of high
testosterone dudes aren't going to be
told what they can and can't do it's one
of the last bastions of masculinity
right exactly you know I mean not for
not for nothing it's it's and and it
people will say there's toxicity and
stuff but it's totally not because those
the guys like you are so well trained so
disciplined and so focused it is not
like just you know like you were talking
earlier like just raw emotion you have
to be smart we were talking earlier
about getting under your opponent's skin
and talking talking trash and how how
that's an important part and I think
that that's a good thing for young men
to do I like I think young men should
get into Jujitsu you know especially
like young people I think you'd be fine
like and then if you you get older and
you want to get into striking sports
that you know more power to you but like
that kind of stuff is really good for
young men because it's a great way to
get expel energy you learn about
yourself you learn about respecting
other people and you know learning your
limits and stuff so I think that I think
that the UFC plays an important role
today for young men
um to to be able to express their their
masculinity in a positive way
I love the uh I crushed his dreams you
know
yeah so
all his dreams
just kicked off YouTube saying some mean
words you know I get locked in the cage
it's okay if I leave someone to pull
blood but oh dang he said some mean
words cancel that guy
that's the funny thing though I like we
talk about all the time how in movies
there's murder there's death there's
chaos but then someone 10 years ago did
a bad joke so they gotta get fired from
their job yeah they say nothing about in
fact they cheer you on that you're you
and another guy are attempting to
mercilessly beat each other to prove
that you're the better fighter and
they're like that's cool and then you're
like I like Donald Trump they're like
shut it down they're like that's
violence
oh my God not the actual show itself
they're like well you know we understand
fighting is a sport but no you know like
it's like it's almost like
the leftist version of UFC is two guys
going to a ring and start talking about
how much who likes Trump more than the
other guy
you like Trump the most it's two guys
saying things about why Trump is good
why they like Western civilizations
gendering each other yep and they're
like it's just the most violence they've
ever seen who can take it for the
longest oh my God
you said Trump beat up my dad I'm
tapping
it's too much it's too much and then
it's like there's low blows dude just
literally the
the micro uh microaggression Division
I was watching I was watching that fight
a couple weeks ago where um I can't
remember who it was uh who was it was it
um but one guy accidentally hit the
other guy in the nuts and then they
immediately backs off and he puts his
like sorry about that and they're like
no it's cool it's cool we can go again
like that's like a big No-No right like
you know yeah we like you know that's
not that's not Sportsman like yeah it's
not a sportsman-like but you know
sometimes In the Heat of battle you know
it's tough to control your weapons you
know sometimes you're throwing a body
kick and it goes a little low it might
hit the nuts but that's why we wear a
cup in there so you can't feel that you
get kicked in the nuts you're not gonna
feel that with the cup on so all right
on yeah so I just but I imagine if the
leftists are getting in the ring it's
like you have a moment where someone
says something and they're like whoa
whoa whoa whoa like that that's an
illegal move you can't say that that's
too violent you know saying something
like Trump 2024 and they're like whoa
whoa
the real extreme stuff is that's not a
penis yeah that's a wound that's what
sucks that's not a vagina that's what
sucks about the media MMA media they're
all liberal like they all hate Trump
they all just they all just bash them
constantly and they don't want to give
me a platform they never want to speak
to me so you know it's just funny
because none of them none of them are
actual journalists none of them have
journalism degrees but they want to act
like they're journalists I mean I I I'll
I hate the journalism degree thing I
suppose there was yeah shame is a
journalist I think back in the day it
probably made some sense we were I was
talking about this today with my family
that we're you know we're in we're in
West Virginia in the small town the
newspaper used to just be like a
bulletin board seriously like the news
was like a guy fell off his ladder and
hurt his leg you live in the city and
you pick up the newspaper it's like John
fell yesterday and you're like oh John
fell wow and there's only a few thousand
people so most people knew sort of who
everybody was now nobody cares at all
about who their neighbor is and you can
have a house burned down across the
street from you and be like what
happened that was a fire I don't even
know who lived there now like we
completely separated ourselves from from
all information on this stuff well with
the political bias it's extra bizarre
and and you know you're talking about
the UFC here and the fact that UFC
journalists are on the left I understand
that journalists are usually uh lefties
but UFC is not like some flowery
left-wing thing that's why it's so
bizarre right yeah they want us all to
be betas but we're all Alphas you know
they don't want you know masculine men
in society you know they that's not
their agenda it doesn't fit their agenda
I just don't like are they doing their
little like critical theory analysis on
the fights or how does that even work I
I I I think the the reason they're
I think UFC allows like you know like I
was saying Dana White because it's like
high testosterone guys who are just like
after you've been punched in the face so
many times words kind of roll off your
back like they didn't even happen it
doesn't matter but these journalists are
genuinely terrified words they hurt them
yeah these Millennials these genziers
who have never experienced anything and
it's funny because people are we've had
a couple super chats we're like these
these guys have never even been punched
in the face like talking about us and
like we're gonna sit here and talk with
you and it's like no I definitely been
punched in the face bro yeah I've been
uh I've and uh I've been in in in uh
I'll keep it light like conflict crisis
and and I don't want to say overt War
but I've been in places where people are
shooting at each other and I've watched
people die not that I've been directly
punched in the face I've had anti I've
had antifa try to punch me in the face
but I mean look like listen I'll put it
this way oh oh I'm a white Bell in Jiu
Jitsu so I know what it's like to get
wrapped up okay so I know
but I'm here to say like fair point like
I don't I I have I have no problem being
like I have no idea what it's like to go
up against the greatest fighters in the
world and win or lose and these these
these leftists act like they do know I
know and I totally get that and I I
agree but I just don't know how anyone
could hear me speak and come to the
conclusion that no one's ever punched me
in the face
are you kidding me oh my gosh oh I think
the best thing about MMA media is just
they all write with their their bias and
their feelings they don't write
impartial journalism they don't say they
don't call a spade a spade you know they
dance around it and it's just sad what
do you think you think most Fighters are
probably right leaning
I would say it's a mix I'd say it's half
and half but I'm like how do you how do
you be a fighter and a leftist I just
don't understand that yeah true I mean
some of the guys are vegetarians or
vegans and all about the soy boy life
and safe spaces and this and that wow
and I think it's also like the
particular brand of left-wing politics
right because I don't think a lot of I
mean maybe I'm wrong but I don't think a
lot of them are going to be like
feminists but I could definitely see
like the BLM thing but I could see
appealing to men in the MMA but these
these these vegan Fighters they're not
like heavyweights right no they're like
middleweights lighter weights because I
don't I I I'm not trying to rag on
anybody's vegan I got no problem with
that you know live your life do what you
want to do just please be healthy and if
you are awesome yeah but it's really
hard to maintain higher weights like I
was I was reading interviews with uh
Hemsworth Chris Hemsworth talking about
playing the role of Thor and he was he
was saying he was eating thousands of
calories of Fish and Chicken every day
to try and maintain that muscle mass and
it's really really hard constant
training eating like crazy and then once
you stop you start going back down
so I'm like
I don't know I I kind of feel like maybe
it's just my bias but if you're if if if
if you can take a hit if you can fight
at the highest level how are you gonna
be the kind of person that's like words
are violence you know what I mean you're
gonna be like I don't care what you call
me dude I just got punched in the face
it hurts well that's the other like I I
think a lot of it is just based on this
is my side of the aisle again you
mentioned like the BLM thing uh I could
totally see that and I think a lot of it
just becomes like tribal politics you
know my family was Democratic growing up
or my family's Republican growing up and
that's why I'm into this and not you
know my gender studies Professor told me
words are violence or something like
that I would suspect most of the people
in the UFC on the left aren't coming at
it from the blue haired college student
angle yeah no most Fighters you know
didn't go to college and yeah they're
rather dumb so I mean they get most of
their information from either social
media or mainstream media and when we
know how how controlled that is you know
and how much fake news is out there so
you know these these kids in fighting
are a lot of sheep you know they don't
they can't think for themselves or do do
the research to find out the real
information they just read a news
article like that on New York Times and
they just believe what it says
automatically let's uh let's jump to
this viral story this one's so good
ladies and gentlemen we have this on The
Daily Mail
pregnant New York City nurse accused of
taking a city bike from a black man
outside hospital is named as friends
start GoFundMe to pay her legal bills
and lawyer shares receipts that proves
the bike was hers all right here's the
story a viral video over the weekend
showed a white woman yelling for help as
some black teenagers surround her and
one guy has his hand on the bike saying
this is not your bike this is my bike
they started claiming that she was
racist that she was trying to steal the
bike from this young black man and that
she was putting his safety in Jeopardy
the hospital suspended her pending an
investigation
we have this tweet from Ben Crump he
said this is unacceptable a white woman
was caught on camera attempting to steal
a city bike from a young black man in
New York City she grossly tried to
weaponize her tears to paint this man as
a threat this is exactly the type of
behavior that has endangered so many
black men in the past the first thing I
noticed when I see this is that she's
actually on the bike
she's literally on the bike and he's not
and he's grabbing the bike and laughing
so how is it so these City bikes the way
they work they're in the rack you walk
up you scan the QR code and the unlocks
the bike and you can take it out how is
it that he walked up did not get on the
bike scanned it then did she run up at
this pregnant woman she's six months
pregnant by the way did she run up and
jump on the bike and try taking it from
him that's what Ben Crump is arguing so
her lawyer so this is the story that was
going up not only did they go they put
out a story saying that she was a racist
trying to steal the bike from this black
teenager journalists went to her home in
New York City and started going to her
neighbors and and saying look this this
is your neighbor this is what she did
what do you think and there are these
people being like wow that looks racist
I can't believe she would do that think
about how nightmarish it is to live in
one of these places I can't even imagine
wanting to live in a place like that
where you have to worry about uh the
media going to your neighbors accusing
you of racism and a totally fabricated
story Ben Crump is the most incredible
race Hustler I have ever seen in my life
that dude is Shameless and he he just
gets on any any any court case or
whatever that he can he's just right
there planting his uh his flag looking
for them dollars so wait so she had the
receipts that showed that this was her
bike this guy was trying to take it from
her on what basis did he decide to
report that she was stealing the bike
from him just the picture he saw the
picture and said well well she has the
best they filmed it okay they they
filmed her and and said like this is
brilliant stuff this is Con level
brilliant grifting when you're
committing the crime accuse the other
person of committing the crime and film
them and then if they don't give you
what you want you can upload the video
and make them the bad guy that's Rules
for Radicals right I would use your
opponent of what you're doing I was
talking about this when I I did a
segment for my morning show an old
contract called a reverse pickpocket
what you do is you take a wallet with a
night with you put your ID in it like an
old dummy ID and then maybe some I don't
know a couple bucks or something you
slip it into the bag of bag or pocket of
someone else then accuse them of robbing
you and that this gets other bystanders
or even the police wow to Rob them on
your behalf so what happens is you say
help that person just robbed me and they
took my phone they took they took my
they took my wallet and then phone's
hard because yeah yeah but if you say
they took my wallet you can say they
took other things too exactly yeah so so
the way the com would work is you drop
the dummy wallet in their coat pocket or
something then you call the police or
you you ask for help when they when they
say look in his pocket the victim is
going what are you talking about I
didn't do anything and they go empty
your pockets then the person pulls a
wallet out of their pocket there it is
that's my wallet open it's got my ID in
it when they open it and your ID's in it
they say boom this proves it and I say
and my cash I had 40 bucks in there no
there's no cash in here where's my 40
bucks and they take the 40 bucks from
the victim and give it to you you can
actually get police to arrest the
victims and then they'll often just be
like here's your cash there sorry
there's an old con people used to pull
and there's sophisticated versions of it
too they wait till someone leaves an ATM
and then people will leave the receipts
at the ATM showing how much money they
have on them then your body reverse
pickpockets then you call the police and
say that person did it the wallet on
them is proof the cop doesn't even need
to get a statement or any evidence the
wallet on them is proven off and the cop
will say upon stopping the perpetrator
we found the wallet in question proving
that the theft took place we returned
the money to the victim wow crazy right
this is what these guys are basically
doing they're they're trying to you know
here's what I think they were trying to
do
when this this happens a lot with these
with these Bike Share things you unlock
the bike with your phone and then you
ride it around and it charges you I
think per hour or you can be a member or
something so what they'll do is they'll
wait for someone to unlock a bike take
the bike from them and then bike stairs
yeah bikes on them because the bike
doesn't have a camera on or anything
like so you can't you can't track and
now if if I use my phone to unlock a
bike and they take it it's all on you
I'll pay for it that's right I paid for
it I think they're trying to steal the
bike from her that makes sense to get
away with it they said she's stealing
the bike from me and it actually worked
for a second until she was able to
publish the receipts proving it was
actually her bike they took from her wow
crazy right that is really crazy who
wants to live in this place this is this
is in New York Hustler's gonna hustle
yeah yeah look at this this is uh what
is it it's right by just just north of
Union Square
they can reveal the nurse's City bike
receipts which your lawyer claims proves
the number on the handlebars of the bike
she was clutching in the footage so you
can see in the picture
560-3915 and they publish the receipt
560-3915 wow
welcome to to the the new country I
guess well he also immediately took it
to not just a race-baiting place a
racist Place she's weaponizing her white
woman Tears like you mean she's crying
because someone's trying to steal her
bike from her I don't think she was
really crying though it does seem fake
like they accused her of fake crying and
the reason I think a lot of people cited
against her is that she's screaming for
help no one helps her then she grabs his
phone then they grab it back then she
starts crying and then the guy behind
her goes get a different bike and then
she just gets off the bike and stops
crying
so I kind of feel like she wasn't as
distressed as she's making out to be but
she was still the victim trying to
figure out how to win this in some way
because she doesn't have the physical
ability to do so and part of me is just
kind of like I'm gonna say it I'm gonna
say it guys she lives in New York the
likelihood that a woman a millennial
woman in New York voted conservative or
for law order is almost zero she likely
but but you know what I'm hoping it's
stuff like this that wakes people like
her up right
true that's what you hope for but it
never never seems to she's why I don't
live there yeah that's why I decide not
to live in these places we we keep
saying over and over people should get
out of New York City get out of the
cities and stuff I mean every day you
see more and more people that can't
leave
speaking up and saying things like I
miss Rudy Giuliani like we saw that
woman today and you know the people that
are on the uh the subway are happy that
the guy saved him because there are
people that can't leave and it's it's
you know hard for some people to just be
like I gotta up and you know if you got
family or if you don't have a lot of
money or whatever there's a million
reasons people could be attached to to a
city but when you hear the average
person that's stuck and can't leave
start saying I missed the guy that was
the Law and Order guy that has also been
basically lambasted for the past six
seven years in the in the media because
he supported the wrong president you
know when you've got all of that
propaganda but New Yorkers are still
like I remember what it was like when
Giuliani was the was the mayor and I
want that back you know you get people
saying things like they want Michael
Bloomberg back and that's that that's
really the population speaking about
what they want you know I can't imagine
what it's like to be stuck there and I
feel I feel terrible for the people they
are they launched a GoFundMe for her
and uh I think she's going to be in for
a rude awakening when GoFundMe bans
their their their fundraising effort
because GoFundMe is the left and give
send go is the right this woman her
family they don't know what's going on
they don't understand I would not be
surprised if GoFundMe removes this
because she is a racist white woman who
tried stealing a bike from a black man
and she's a Karen and then she's gonna
have to learn the hard way why she'll
have to go but but maybe not maybe maybe
GoFundMe allows it I'd be surprised if
they do to be honest
she's raised four grand so far for 35
000 goal well
no I mean it's interesting how this is
getting flipped around people are making
the argument that her calls for help
were insincere okay but one person is
actually committing a crime on camera
here and it's not her so why is she the
person who all the public attention is
on I also want to point out because this
was left out and I also was not aware of
this until I just learned that she's
also pregnant
six months pregnant yes I said oh you do
okay sorry that totally went over my
head and so I'm saying like what when
this young black man was was standing
next to the bike and scanning it this
six months pregnant oh yeah that's right
jumps onto the bike give me that dude
he's six months pregnant women stealing
bikes from black men in New York is a
real problem happens every day
apparently yeah apparently it was so
shocking because Donald Trump had to get
involved yeah
like what do they think is I don't
understand what they think is happening
like this pregnant woman tried taking a
bike from this group of men a race a
note a racist pregnant because they
brought race into it she was using her
white woman tears a racist white woman
like these pregnant white women are
victimizing minorities by stealing their
bikes it doesn't stop happening are they
are they saying that this pregnant white
woman saw a group a group of young black
teenagers walked up and said give me
that bike and then jumped on it right
it's just wild to me that's what they're
actually going and she had to prove her
innocence because the media was saying
she made them unsafe because Ben Crump
called her racist unreal you know look
man I I
do you expect me to donate to her as
well
like the penny thing I get they're
trying to put him in prison you know
what I mean they did try destroying This
Woman's life but this is why I said it
before and I'll say it again at what
point
are these people in these cities
this is this is what they how they
choose to live yeah yeah I I get it
we've gotta we've gotta win these fights
maybe maybe the reason we donate to her
is because we want people to see that if
you know you will not be victimized by
these these these con artists well this
is the problem right I mean you can
donate to people who this kind of thing
happens to and I think that's a good
thing but when the people who perpetrate
the lies don't face any negative
consequences it just keeps happening
exactly there's literally zero downside
to spreading a lie like this you know
you know what I was thinking we were we
were talking about
um
we're talking about we're talking about
history earlier and it's uh partly
because the work we're doing in West
Virginia these are small towns and I was
saying like any any story you've heard
throughout history just imagine it with
a hundred times less people
because we're used to growing up in
these big dense Urban environments or we
see like a we see like a football game
and there's 60 000 people and we're like
wow so when you think back to the
Coliseum you're imagining this huge full
Coliseum and the gliders fight it's
probably a couple hundred people yeah
like just a few hundred these Great
Battles of History and we're imagining
and it's like I think I think what was
Gettysburg like 10 15 000 or something
like that oh no no way more more people
died at Gettysburg than died in the
entire Vietnam War oh wow well I knew
that more um
Americans died in uh the Civil War was
something like 700 000 Americans died in
the the Civil War overall yeah more
people died at Gettysburg than died in
the whole Vietnam War there was 54 57
000 people died in Vietnam and there was
more people that died oh wow yeah it was
160 000 people present at Gettysburg
that's a lot of people a lot of people
so okay civil war Civil War excluded
it was because I was like reading about
some historical fight and it was
mentioning like this great battle and it
was a few hundred people fighting and I
was like oh wow we we think by today's
standards and maybe because of the Civil
War we assume there's way more people
but there were a lot less people before
the 1900s before the Industrial
Revolution and before the before the you
know I mean we talk about oh like energy
is life and there's all this talk about
you know limiting energy and there's a
lot of the green initiatives and stuff
that's just going to cause Mass death
because energy is life if you look at a
chart of world population it's not just
the Industrial Revolution it's oil oil
is so energy dense that once people
discovered that oil could be used in all
the things that it can be the population
on Earth skyrocketed I mean it's like
it's literally like it makes Lance's uh
left-handed chart look ridiculous I mean
it's straight up left-handed Church well
so Colby I'd like to ask and obviously
don't answer if this is not something
you're public about but uh do you or
have you ever had to live in one of
these blue places
yeah yeah I had to live in Oregon for
most of my life and you know it wasn't
as political they didn't you know make
it so you know so much division like
there is today and and left first ride
and trying to make it a white versus
black thing to divide this country more
so it was never like that until like a
couple years ago when antifa started
raiding it and you know it just became
such a democrat-run state so it's this
time of day is just so much different
than it was you know a decade ago and so
you you grew up there yeah it must be
really hard to see it fall apart yeah
it's really hard because I I love that
that state it's such a beautiful you
know State yeah a lot of mountains a lot
of outdoor stuff to do and you know
that's why I was born and raised and
that's where all the hard work was put
into to get to where I am today the top
of the mountain of the UFC world so you
know I'll never go back now seeing it
the way it's run I'll never go back I
don't I don't even go to visit you know
so yeah somebody somebody to ask a good
question they said why is it on the
receipt the time is blurred out as if to
imply that she went back later to find
this bike I'll say two things the first
I'll say a couple things I have no idea
you want to pull this up I have no idea
why they uh blurred the time on the
receipt that's the Daily Mail
but you wouldn't be able to find the
bike like if someone took the bike and
then rode away with it you don't know
where it would end up the other thing is
the New York Post says the first receipt
reviewed by the post shows the bike was
taken out before it was re-locked one
minute later which Mourinho said is the
bike scene in the video the second
receipt shows another bike being taken
out a minute later which is the bike she
switched to so the story was that when
she was she she purchased the bike and
tried to take it they they pushed her
back in and wouldn't let her leave with
it which is why the receipt says zero
because it was it was it was unlocked
and then re-locked right away so that's
the bike and you can see the the number
on the on the bike in question but other
than that I have no idea where the Daily
Mail I'm I'm assuming it looks at the
Daily Mail is the one that redacted the
uh the time stamp on it for some reason
yeah no idea
yep very strange
should we jump to the next law order
story all right here you go you guys
ready system in uh in the criminal
justice system stealing luggage from
airports
in New York City the members of the
Biden Administration to commit these
crimes or given raises
arrested as fugitive of Justice and
Luggage theft case Sam Britton stole bag
from airports in Minnesota and Nevada in
2022. he probably stole a lot more than
that and I don't they call them
non-binary I don't think it was
non-binary I think he's a kleptomaniac
and what he would do is he would steal
their clothes and then wear them on
camera because that gave him some kind
of exhilaration
like this is what he would do you can
see here in these images he's wearing
the clothing he stole from these women I
don't think it's about wearing a women's
clothing I think it's about
imagine this if you wore a suit nobody
would know there was a stolen suit yeah
you steal you steal a suitcase you find
a suit you put it on you wear it on a
show it's on my bag is that my suit I
can't tell
but then in the suitcase is a suit and
is a frilly fancy dress with moons on it
and he's like this but you know he stole
it no for real he wants he wants to
stand in front of everybody and scream
this is a stolen outfit that I am
wearing and smile as they clap for him
that's what does it for him yeah that's
what that's that's what he gets and the
bite Administration is all about it man
that's some sick fetish types you can be
weird but you know just don't be weird
around our kids don't be weird you know
in public you know do whatever you want
to do this is America it's freedom of
you know we have so many freedoms here
so do whatever you want to do my
enclosed door just don't do weird stuff
in public and don't do weird stuff with
my luggage
that's all that's all we're asking is
like leave the kids alone and don't
break laws yeah dude it's like a
two-hour desk would you get that little
airplane
fly and get that little slip in your
luggage that says you've been subjected
to a random TSA search you can't find
your dress you look on television this
guy's wearing it you're like wait a
minute that's that's it's yeah
that's literally what happened what was
he did he was like a nuclear regulation
guy yeah it's so weird like how why was
he in the news
he wasn't like a prominent admin a
Cabinet member because it was his
non-binary scene it was like a Biden
appointment I think he was uh I think he
was a groundbreaking pick or something
like that was nuclear diversity which
makes us stronger yeah former nuclear
waste expert from the for the Department
of energy they were like he's non-binary
it turned out he was just some kind of
like klepto fetishist what would you
call the kleptophilia something like
that yeah that's got an arousal from
stealing left Ophelia that's what they
call Mr Steal Your Girl You Know What I
Mean
Sheamus uh I mean I think I'm if I
understand correctly the only reason
that he got appointed is because he was
you know they could they could promote
that they had a non-binary a member of
the the new religion uh in the position
klepto lagnia by the way what
kleptolagnia lagnia that's a l-a-g-n-i-a
what what is that yeah that's what
uh the state of being sexually aroused
by theft
yeah yeah
uh so I learned another term that
shouldn't have to exist the other one
we'll talk about in the members only
show yeah we gotta we gotta we got a
outrageous members only show come up
here tonight having to do with a lot if
you found me on Twitter you know what
I'm talking about
like we don't we don't we don't say such
things on YouTube no I don't think I
even said anything too egregious on
Twitter I guess but we stated a fact
well let's just we'll save it let's keep
let's keep talking about the crazy guy
who stole the clothes
what did he steal he said he was ordered
to pay over three thousand six hundred
seventy dollars to the owner of a bag he
stole some one of the one-of-a-kind
stuff that's um that a lady had made she
made her own clothes and stuff and it
was like expensive for her to make and
it was one of a kind and and he jacked
it and then I think actually that yeah
the one on the right there that that uh
the red thing was was custom made
actually no maybe even the I think both
of those I I think custom made he's
wearing these one-of-a-kind artistic
modeling pieces like the clothing he's
wearing was designed he probably stole a
bunch of bags and threw away all of the
stuff from Kohl's in Old Navy
and then he finds the unique stuff and
says it's it's basically like returning
to the scene of a crime you know like in
the in the movies and the serial killer
is like standing outside the police line
smiling and staring and they're like
What's this guy doing they can't prove
anything what do you do like that's what
he was trying to do and I think
it's it's like uh what was it was it was
it King of the Hill or whatever what
show was it where oh no a Family Guy did
it where Lois is stealing everything
because she gets excited from it oh yeah
and then she like puts the cigarette on
her arm like I'm alive like instead of
skydiving or bungee jumping this dude
steals women's clothing and then wears
it on TV Lois does have an addictive
personality and Peggy Hill was a
sociopath like she's like a narcissistic
sociopath serious yeah she's very into
herself
that's an understatement she was an evil
woman that character man that's what
inspires people like this I guess who go
around stealing clothes yeah it's like
this dude's from one of those shows and
it's just it's real life it's like it
feels like a thing you'd see on Family
Guy but this is something that actually
happened like numerous times yo he was
as part of an adult diversion he was
required to write a letter of apology
returns stolen items to the victim and
complete three days of community service
Brenton also agreed to undergo a mental
health evaluation oh my gosh wow because
he was facing five years in jail he had
to pay 3670 bucks over a bag he stole in
December from the Harry Reid
International Airport he was seeing
surveillance footage of the stolen bag
in July
at the time of his arrest in Vegas the
Biden admins at the incident of an
alleged crimes were non-political uh
where a non-political issue refused to
comment in February 2023 a houston-based
fashion designer publicly accused him of
stealing her bag from Reagan National
Airport in 2018
Isaac Thomson wrote on Twitter that she
had lost a bag containing custom outfits
after traveling to DC to display her
designs at an event after Brenton's
thefts were reported by the media
Thompson said she recognized her items
in the images of Brenton filed a
complaint with police in Houston and was
subsequently contacted by the FBI well
at least they're doing something I guess
you know
if anything they're stopping this guy
from stealing clothes yeah they're also
suppressing information but why why like
so if he already got arrested and
charged what's the current arrest for he
was taken into custody May 17th at his
home in Maryland at the request of the
Metropolitan Washington Airport
he was taken to the Montgomery County
Detention Center and held overnight in
prep for an appearance before judge
Victor delpino on May 18th which was
today he is being held without bond yo
that's like really close to here it's
like that's like a few miles away can
you imagine being a grown man and being
forced to write an apology note
the worst thing I've ever heard did he
have to write it 50 times on a
chalkboard I will not steal women's
luggage I will not steal him his life
tough one
man I just I I can't wait to take the
present time
say like I am so sorry for it's like 30
30 some odd miles away from here
wow it's like it's like relatively close
I guess we're super close to DC so it's
not surprising yeah oh that's right by
it's right by um who's that member of
Congress who uh lied about me and
everybody else on the January 6
committee uh Rat Raskin oh okay yeah
he's right by right by there
the uh the designer that he uh stole
from
I can't pronounce that
um
son Thompson I don't know that's what it
is that what is that asaya Thompson one
yeah and I mean she's still out there
doing stuff and she makes cool stuff but
man
he got himself into a pickle
has any one of a kind has anyone gone
through any of his other photos and like
trying to track try to track down
yeah his clothing I think someone did
actually I think someone that's how they
found some other stuff no way yeah they
were like oh my gosh wow yeah it
definitely has more the adults are back
in charge as they say that's the crazy
thing it's like the uh that what they
say is always the opposite
the adults are back in charge and
they're clearly not Pete booty judge
isn't even oh did you see that who that
that that uh article about people to
judge
that said that yeah he was a genius yes
and a bunch of other crazy I should pull
this one up dude did you guys remember
in the 2016 election like right towards
the end there right before it was time
to vote you got all of these people
claiming all these people in the media
is saying oh yeah like I know people who
worked with Hillary they said she's
super nice it was all it was like that's
really weird that this is the first time
I'm ever hearing it and I heard it like
five times on the radio in the last week
well I mean look the media has been in
bed with the Democrats and with the you
know the clintons and and probably the
Obamas and stuff for the better part of
at least a decade so for them to just
say oh hey this is the person that we
endorse and and run propaganda another
thing there was a there was a law that
prevented the the federal government
from propagandizing the American people
and that was repealed in one of the
ndaas when when uh Barack Obama was in
office I think it was like 2011 or
something like that but there used to be
a law that said the government cannot
propagandize the American people that
law gets repealed in ndaa next thing you
know social media companies are doing
their best to shove whatever the
Democrat Party wants down people's
throats and actually they feel obligated
to right I mean probably because they've
well no they felt so bad that Trump got
elected they just needed to make sure
something like that didn't happen again
yeah
I blame CNN Jeff Zucker among other
things they uh they were so obsessed
with them they did us all the favor and
gave him free five billion dollars in
Free Press coverage and so now they're
terrified their ratings are lower than
Newsmax because they don't seem to get
it if you want to be a member of the
cult you got to be a full-fledged member
of the cult yep but you can't try and be
a cult member and a journalist because
then they don't but but they had Donald
Trump on a Town Hall they had the front
runner for the Republican Party On TV
and they they debated him and that was
not good enough yeah and so they're
losing audience members for doing so
yeah they that look CNN you want to be
in the cult be in the cult if CNN
reported real news they would have
tremendous ratings could you imagine if
the entire time scene existed they were
pushing back on russiagate lies they
were saying like these these reports are
not true there's no evidence to adjust
it then people would be watching them
and all they had to compete with Fox
News all the I had to do was tell the
truth right like you could tell an
unbiased true like factual story The the
way that Donald Trump was covered for
his entire presidency once he got into
office if you covered any other
president in the same way with that much
negative press you're going to have a
population that believes that he is evil
because the average person doesn't spend
the time necessary and they shouldn't
honestly they should go out and do
things with their lives and live their
lives but they don't spend the time
necessary to really dig down and be like
well this isn't true that they said and
that isn't true there's so many people
that still to this day believe that
Donald Trump uh the very fine people lie
about the the
um unite the right rally the way that he
was talking about it there's still
people that believe that and that's
probably what your average low
information voter thinks I want to read
uh for everybody this wired article on
Pete bootage titled Pete booty judge
loves God beer and his electric Mustang
sure the U.S Secretary of Transportation
has thoughts on Building Bridges but
infrastructure occupies a sliver of his
voluminous mind oh God this is um I'm
gonna read this for you so you can
understand the depravity of the American
corporate press and when Michael malice
says the corporate press is the enemy of
the people you'll understand why after I
read you two paragraphs I hope you guys
are ready and please don't be mad at me
for having to read this to you you you
need to hear it the Curious mind of
people to judge holds much of much of
its functionality in reserve even as he
discusses railroads and Airlines down to
the pointless data that it that is his
current stock and trade the U.S
Secretary of Transportation comes off
like a Mensa black card holder who might
have a secret go habit or a three second
Rubik's Cube solution or a knack for
supplying off the top of his head the
day of the week for a random date in
1404 along with a non-condescending
history of the Julian and Gregorian
calendars as secretary Buddha judge and
I talk in his under furnished corner
office one afternoon in early spring I
slowly became aware that his cabinet job
requires only a modest portion of his
cognitive Powers other mental faculties
no kidding are apportioned to The Iliad
Puritan historiography and nosguard's
spring though not in the original
Norwegian fortunately he was willing to
devote yet another apps in his Cathedral
mind to making his ideas about three
Mighty themes neoliberalism masculinity
and Christianity Christianity
intelligible to me he is being worshiped
as if he is Holy Spirit that is that's
that's exactly what it is it's like
that's the way that they you'd approach
like a cardinal or like that's the way a
Catholic would approach a cardinal or
Sheamus right well in what way well like
saying all these nice things
I mean there's like there's a respect
that's due to authority figures but the
this is obviously like the media just
trying to worship somebody because he's
their guy right but it's like to me off
as he's it's like the the religious
aspect they're they're saying that he's
a pure holy representation of their
religion I think insurance is trying to
date him
the excerpts posted on Twitter I thought
I was reading Babylon b or the onion
like to say that he's uh what did they
say he was willing to vote in another
apps in his Cathedral mind to make these
themes intelligible to me I'm like
that's not real is it none of it none of
it was realistic this just like they
just said that this is what it's like
this is what he seems like that he's he
seems like he'd have a MasterCard he
seems like he does none of it's actually
real it's just the biggest puff piece
are they trying to prop him up for 2024
I hope not who do they have the
Democrats have anybody actually you know
what they should do that because then he
will he will not do so well yeah yeah I
strongly believe that it that it's the
lgbtq AI plus religion and he is looked
at as holy no he's not they hate him
yeah the the the real devout dude with
the the Loosely devout like the people
that would be in the media not the
people that are like the theorists that
are writing the books and stuff but the
the initiated but not the the thought
leaders they're the ones that would be
like oh people to judge he's a member of
the LGBT community we want to put him in
a position where he where we want to
have him in this good light because he's
an authority Etc so here you go Buddha
judge whose father was a renowned
Marxist
Scholar's father listen people to
judge's father is the guy that
translated Antonio Graham she's prison
notebooks which outline uh outlined
cultural Marxism in in its entirety the
idea that Marxist needed to infiltrate
Infiltrate The Western countries in
media and in the um in the in the the
culture before getting into the
government that was all Antonio Graham
she written about in in the 20s when he
was in
um an Italian prison the guy was an
Albanian uh communist it's he's the guy
that and Buddha Chad's father was the
guy that translated all he's a total
Marxist they're all communities so is
this like a Young Avengers kind of thing
where the marxists are they're you know
we got to get his kid well it's also
interesting like they do this right
often and I I can't remember who said
this initially but uh Aaron McIntyre
says this they like to skin your
religion alive and then like wear its
skin as a suit and so this whole idea
that Pete Buddha judge is this devout
religious man when he's promoting
homosexuality and he's a Christian who
cares a lot about God well it's
interesting in one of the debates he
referenced that like oppressing the poor
into frauding workers are very serious
sins and it's true that those are among
four sins that are listed as sins that
crowd to have in for vengeance and one
of those other four is something that
people to judge is very proud of doing
is all I'll say because yeah I I think
it's fair to say in any context things
they take the religion I think it was uh
Tucker Carlson who is he talking about
the what what was the what was remember
Tucker Carlson said they're not a
religion anymore they're not even
Christian it's like oh oh I think
yeah probably yeah yeah
oh yeah consistently arguing fired what
they're doing is in line with what the
Bible says for whatever reason they
decide that it's in line with what the
Bible says yeah there's a lot of people
who have done that for a very long time
for sure but but I mean to the left no
no I I get what you're saying I get what
you're saying and I wouldn't disagree
with that at all
um and political leaders for all of
history have tried to use religion as a
skin suit so to speak right we're going
to hollow out the actual norms and
valleys but we're going to take the
parts of it that we like and we're gonna
you know promote those and then try to
use this veneer of religiosity to
suggest that we're devout and serious
people who care about morality to the
public I mean do you think Buddhist
cares a whole lot about morality is
deeply concerned you do you think he's
like a really good guy who stays up late
at night thinking about real moral
problems and how to solve I don't I
don't think he thinks about any of the
stuff we talk about no I think he was
offered a do-nothing job they said drop
out of the race and endorse Biden and
we'll give you a cushy jab you'll get
paid you got to do anything and he's
like sounds good to me and then they
appoint him Transportation secretary
then the train blows up and they're like
where's Buddha judge and he's like
he gets a phone call it's like it says
White House on his phone and he's like
yeah and they're like where are you at
he's like too busy don't breastfeed my
new kid I'm watching I'm watching reruns
of X-Files and they're like you need to
come in because everyone's mad he's like
you told me I have to do any work
like oh well no you gotta you gotta put
on the hard hat and come out here for a
little bit that's what he did where the
the uh the vest orange Fest yeah how
many Die Hard bootage supporters you
think there are in the MMA or UFC
probably slim to none all right well
interesting okay there are so there are
a lot of people but not that woke me so
it might be one yeah the journalists
probably all levels oh yeah
I don't know man I I wonder if
I wonder if something like this exists
this article because they need to lay on
the gravitas right now they're in
desperate need of a candidate for 2024
they have no one they tried Buddha judge
last time clearly does not work so
instead of doing a long-storied career
with articles popping up saying good
things they cram it all into one he's a
Mensa genius who Graces me because they
need something
I mean who are they gonna run Biden
I don't even know if Biden's gonna be
around I'm trying to be mean but you
know seriously yeah like he's well past
how old is he right now
79 yeah I think he's at like 80 81 maybe
is he 81 it's like 81. let's take a look
at Joe Budden why Joe Biden now is 79
he'll be 80. he'll be like 83 80. he's
80. 80 years old yeah yeah uh November
20th 1840 uh
I did say 18 and I said November 20th
1942.
1842. you know what I'm gonna be honest
here's the thing this headline loves God
I mean doesn't keep the Commandments uh
beer prop maybe Bud Light maybe Bud
Light Electric Mustang that's got to be
the lamest Mustang I ever heard of yeah
true the whole thing is I just
backtracked that entire article the
voluminous mind the real the reason
they're doing that is
what how do you pronounce that
voluminous voluminous voluminous there's
a lot of it means big yes I know it's
voluminous in mind
I feel like that the whole thing is just
you know a continuation of the
propaganda that the the government now
is just shoving down people's throats I
really think a lot changed after the NDA
was signed that allowed the government
to propagandize people I mean it was the
perfect time with social media being you
know in everyone's pocket right about
that time you know everyone on social
media everyone has a was had a cell
phone by then
um and I think that most people that
that have the Normie opinions you know
unfortunately they're unwittingly
they've unwittingly been completely
propagandized by the most sophisticated
propaganda apparatus ever invented it's
literally in your it's literally people
that choose to be propagandized they
find their tribes to think that the
things that they the people that they
tend to align with most and then they're
just shoved the same you know stories
that that
basically give them the dopamine hit
that they're looking for all the time
yeah
just constant reaffirmation of the
things you believe yeah
foreign
ever a quiet moment on the show it's
like well that's it we just we've solved
everything we did fix it we we fixed
everything we've we've got nothing left
to talk about but Pete booty judge and
that guy who stole those ladies clothes
I think we should talk the fact that
Barack Obama knew about this the steel
dossier being Clinton uh garbage in
there yes tell us more about that well I
mean Barack Obama by the way I thought
you were gonna say Barack Obama knew
that this guy was stealing luggage
clothing he might have known about that
too but you know but I told everyone
uh president Trump before he was in
office and then as soon as when Once
president Trump was in office the doj
continued to investigate all based on
all phony charges they should all go to
jail they should all be tried we can
talk about that all night long yeah
what do you guys think is going to
happen next year uh they're saying
Rhonda Sanders is going to announce he's
running for office next week
I think Ron DeSantis needs to worry
about finishing his job in in Florida he
started a lot of things there you know
with the Disney the legal immigration
what you need to finish what you start
man you got unfinished business over in
Florida it's not his time either he's
turned out though isn't he is he I think
he's just what's what is he on like you
get two terms right is it eight years I
think so yeah maybe right
I'm looking it up
uh let's see can be elected every four
years and uh you're not allowed to serve
consecutive terms blah blah so what does
that mean uh there's a two there's a
term limit
I don't know uh every four years there's
no lifetime limit on the number of times
he or she may be elected oh okay so no
that's not true no yeah two consecutive
terms term limit oh man so he's got one
more and he just got elected last it was
it was uh last year right yeah yeah so
okay so he's got four more years yeah
he's got a lot of work to do I think
he's doing a great job there was a list
from uh his team about all of the
policies he's passed and it's just like
slam dunk after slam dunk so yeah well
with the tournament thing I mean one
problem I have with that is the scumbag
politicians are basically all the same
and there's a lot of them so I don't
know how much term limits really help
there but when you get someone who's
actually good which is so remarkably
rare they end up getting term limited
out and then they can't keep serving
storm limit term limits or or terminal
limits should be on the bureaucracy yeah
so if you're if you're appointed uh you
know FBI had a FBI or if you're in CIA
or whatever any of the bureaucracy uh
positions should have like you know
eight years or whatever then you have to
get out yeah the the bureaucracy is
really where the the administrative
state in you know has all of its power
it makes rules that have the effect of
law without actually being voted on by
the Congress or by the senate or
anything so it's totally independent law
making so I I think that that is our
biggest problem Marjorie Taylor green
filed to impeach Joe Biden again today
fully backed this yes
well I wanna can we just pull up The
Descent I want to ask a few more
questions we'll pull it to disaster
start a little bit because he had I'll
do it yeah no no I I just want to ask
you so I think I mostly agree with you
right like I like what DeSantis is is
doing in Florida and we were talking to
Don Jr about this yesterday I would like
to see Trump go back into the Oval
Office I think it'd be incredible if
he's able to do for so and just go
scorched Earth on the Deep State and all
the the people that that attacked him
do you think I mean how would you feel
about like a DeSantis Trump ticket if
something like that were possible do you
think that DeSantis should strictly stay
in Florida if there were if there was an
opportunity for him and Trump to work
together would you be in favor of that
I mean I'd definitely be in favor of it
if there if there was that opportunity
but you could tell that DeSantis doesn't
want to take a back seat he feels like
entitled like he's America's governor
right now like he's he's not ready for
the national stage you know Donald Trump
will walk circles around him in a
political debate so you know I think
Carey Lake would be a great you know
vice president uh candidate for for
Trump you know she she's a very smart uh
intellectual lady so I think that would
be the right candidate I think you know
we still got unfinished business in
Florida you know we need to you know all
the policies that he's doing he needs to
finish that and you know we need Trump
back in office obviously his policies
worked and you know inflation was at an
all-time low you know our economy was
booming you know our borders were secure
we America was first and yeah you know I
think that DeSantis is controlled
opposition I think he is really I do
think he is yeah
but he's doing such good things you know
what I mean it's like you're getting all
these things that you want in Florida if
it's controlled opposition they're just
giving us everything we want
it's to earn the trust of the people so
that when he runs people believe it
yeah I don't know yeah I mean I just
think Trump's the guy for it now I I
definitely agree with that maybe next
time around yeah I I think I can agree
with that it's it's a complicated one
but I I lean in that direction I lean in
that direction and I think that um we
were talking about this yesterday Trump
he you know he eats every politician
he's on stage with alive like it's
impossible to come out of an interaction
with him looking good it almost never
happens if you're arguing I don't think
I I would hate to see him go up against
the Santas because I do think DeSantis
is doing great things in Florida and I
do think Trump would absolutely shred
him if the two of them got us together I
think Trump did not do that well against
Biden well he struggled with that
because Biden here because here's the
thing Biden is a sad old man with
dementia so you don't shred him the way
you shred other politicians you just let
him talk Trump didn't do that and that
was his biggest mistake in those debates
he should have just let Biden talk but
he didn't he kept interrupting him well
it didn't go well for him because if you
just let Biden talk he ends up sounding
like an idiot all by himself two on one
you know if Chris Wallace was throwing
softball as the bite and then he's
giving him all the tough questions that
Trump yeah I think he was tagged that's
been that way since uh since the the
Mitt Romney and and uh Barack Obama
debate when when uh Romney said
something true and then the the
moderator corrected yeah it's false but
no it was he was he was right you know
moderators have been sticking their nose
in for oh yeah I think I think one of
the issues though is that uh when you've
got someone like Jeb Bush
and Trump's roasting him it's funny when
when Joe Biden gets roasted it's sad
well it's kind of funny too but the
difference is when Joe Biden is on stage
with you and it you know just allowing
him to speak is going to make him look
dumber than any insult you could throw
at him then you just gotta let the guy
speak it's like the Babylon be competing
with reality it's tough exactly exactly
no but that's that's the actual that's a
great way of putting it that's the
actual approach when you're talking with
Joe Biden with Hillary Clinton you know
the moderators in those debates were
also in Hillary's favor and on her side
and they were trying to gang up on Trump
but he smoked her he smoked her it was
it was a thing to behold and we just
didn't see it as well with Biden because
I think there's a different strategy
needed there but I also think at that
time with everything that deep state was
doing and all the insane impeachment
trials you can't blame him for having
them thrown off his A-game and I do want
to say too The Babylon bee often does
write fact-based headlines and I'm not
exaggerating they'll write something
where the story will be you know
politician signs bad policy and then
they'll write the story but in in a
context mocking what they did so it's
still technically the truth you know
like it's hard to think of an example
top my head but they'll write something
like you know polish and signs bill that
every Americans hate and it's like well
they did like that literally happened
and you're making fun of it but you're
telling us the truth about what happened
they do that a lot and then not to
mention not to mention they have that
spreadsheet of all the predictions
they've made that have come true well I
should say all the satirical articles
they've written that have turned out to
be and that have come true eventually
yep that's crazy
dude I mean it happens well look we
don't have news these days only reruns
right it's just the same Cycles keep
appearing over and over and over again
we were I went to a diner today and they
were playing uh
what's that song Sugar Ray someday
someday when my life has passed me but
and I just I heard it and then I said to
everybody's like do you know how old
this song is
what is it like 1994 or something I'm
like that would be like being a kid as a
millennial and some and you go to a
restaurant and they're blasting music
from the early 60s
to us that sounds kind of like a weird
thing like 60s music blasting you know
we play contemporary music and maybe
some 80s 60s was like the oldies now you
go you go to a restaurant you go
somewhere and they're playing music from
the 90s as if it's like modern music and
then uh we were talking about how you
can look at furniture you can look at
appliances and know what decade it's
from not modern stuff interesting like
what after 2010 or something after the
2000s uh like late 90s and on time just
froze I will say there was there was a
kind of unique aesthetic in the early
2000s where everything was kind of
bubbly and curvy it was weird little
post 90s aesthetic that existed for a
little while but after that I think
everything got this combination of like
straight edge with some slight curve to
it and it's pretty much stayed there
because that one the AI took over or the
aliens or something
well like hold on let me look it you're
checking to see when the aliens took
over yeah yeah I'm Google I'm gonna see
if snope has an answer 2012 for me it's
2012 the uh the end of the Aztec
calendar I think it was yeah maybe
that's it maybe that's just one like
that like we were only programmed by the
simulation to go this far you notice
that's when that's when that's when like
what was it I think over half people on
Earth saturation
basically Market saturation of cell
phones like end of 2012 beginning in
2013 and that coincided with the
February members December 2012 was when
the Mayans predicted that there would be
the beginning of a new era Awakening
right they believed that everybody would
be able to understand each other's
thoughts right yeah and I was told that
like in the early 2000s or whatever like
everyone's going to be psychic and I'm
like what
yeah and then I looked back on and I was
like Twitter that's why Elon wanted it
they're fighting over the the you know
the oh the Genesis device the the Nexus
device Wow Let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
where I have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you at about 10 10
p.m it's gonna be fun oh this one's
gonna get gonna get dark I guess because
um the culture War episode for tomorrow
has been canceled and we'll explain why
in the members only show where we talk
about things that we don't say on
YouTube David Toronto says Colby destroy
Leon Scott
I will my brother for forgotten country
and you know the Trump movement I'm
gonna drop Mega bombs on the student's
face and bring this title back to
America where it belongs hell yeah I say
federally says I think you're too hard
on Snowden Greenwald and poitrus have
maintained they got Specific
Instructions Not to indiscriminately
publish or jeopardize anyone active what
you say about snowden's Trove is more
true for Manning it's true for Manning
but the thing about Snowden is that I
believe in an interview with it might
have been uh Colbert or John Oliver I'm
not sure where he admitted to not
actually going through the files and he
did not know what was in the files he
was releasing so I'm not saying he was
right or wrong I'm saying Julian Assange
is a journalist people send him
information he publishes it
whistleblowers come to me publishes and
eat it that's it they're trying to
accuse him of colluding or conspiring or
something that was Un-American Edward
Snowden is a leaker he took a trove of
documents and he leaked them to
journalists that I am not giving a moral
prescription or or or anything I'm just
saying that's what he did there's a
difference so you you can be happy with
what he did I think he revealed a lot of
really important stuff about how they're
spying on us and lying in the you know X
key score all those things very very
important information that was revealed
but I think understanding the
distinction between leaking and being a
journalist it's an important thing again
if you want to Pardon Stone I'm not
saying you shouldn't I think he should
be pardoned but my attitude is more like
yeah okay no I get it Julian Assange
absolutely be pardoned
all right Wayback says yokobi when is
your next fight Leon doesn't seem to
want to fight you
yeah it's uh you know I've been talking
to UFC he turned on a home date in
London UK where he's from you know he
doesn't believe in his people and he
doesn't believe they deserve a
pay-per-view World title fight so now
it's looking like August or September
the fight's gonna go down he's got
nowhere to run nowhere to hide so this
fight's gonna happen 100 for the
Undisputed UFC World title and uh it's
gonna be it's going to be big what is it
what does that look like for you in
between these big fights just training
all the time yeah my lifestyle you know
I'm turning 24 7 365. I'm trading twice
twice a day six days a week wow yeah how
does that work though do you are you
spying with people and fighting
um usually we don't do The Spar until
like training camps you know just
because it's a lot of wear and tear on
the body when you're sparring hard like
fighting someone physically so you know
usually I'm just training more like
techniques like working on my my punches
working on my kicks working on my
wrestling Jitsu and just making sure my
techniques and are are you know world
class are there uh I'm sure a lot of
people who are who are big big fans and
know the stuff better than that you
probably already know but Are there
specific
um martial arts or styles that you
prioritize or that Fighters tend to
prioritize
yeah I think the like most Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu or something yeah like I would say
American wrestling that's the most
prevalent yeah martial art that's the
best martial art because if you're a
wrestler like it's already in someone's
head like I don't want to go to the
ground so even the best strikers they
don't want to do too much because they
don't want to get taken to the ground
and get their face punched in and then
the Jujitsu Fighters are like oh how are
we gonna get the rest of the ground
we're just gonna get punched in the face
so oh wow American wrestling American
wrestling best way for martial arts wow
that's cool
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats
Raymond field says what's the go fund me
for the pregnant lady I think her name
was what was it Sarah comrie
was that it it's something calmery
c-o-m-r-i-e yeah
the line says congrats on having the
next UFC welterweight champion on Tim
much love chaos much love chaos
much love brother appreciate the support
and and uh more congratulations to me
you get to be on you know the Tim cast
podcast you guys one of the smartest
people alive so it's an honor to hear
him talk and and get some knowledge from
him today we'll we'll have we'll have a
lot of fun in the members only for sure
Raymond g Stanley Junior says Tim I want
to do a banger of a super chat I wanted
to do real hard work but
I just called my video Sheamus we synced
up bro we synced up
thank you that is a reference to the
newest Cartoon we put up on men getting
their periods if you guys want to go
over to Freedom tunes and check that out
it was a fun one last night after we
wrapped the show Sheamus is like Tim I
need you to we weren't able to period we
weren't able the the animation got done
too late we were oh we couldn't do it I
said I know we couldn't stop Tim was
originally did the voice but we
literally we ran late on production and
like couldn't get it in Sheamus only
lets me voice uh Dr fauci no we'll we'll
be couple ideas for things only only Dr
fauci
oh let's grab some more
Joe Mallet says BJJ Purple belt can't
understand this I'm often in rougher
chokes also holding a choke for 15
minutes is exhausting he wasn't holding
it for 15 minutes
um is that what they were claiming it
was 15 minutes
I thought I read that somewhere that
didn't seem to make like I don't know
what do you think that makes sense
holding someone down for 15 minutes does
not make any sense maybe like 15 seconds
yeah 15 minutes in a way and in the
video you can see he's got a it's like a
fairly tight choke yeah so yeah and then
and then he and then you see him get up
and he they flip the guy over they put
him in the recovery position the dude's
moving
um look I'm not saying anybody did
anything perfect my view is if you're if
you're like a big dude and you don't
know any technique and someone is
threatening to kill people and you just
decide you're gonna hit him because you
got to stop them you know they're like
getting aggressive and you're gonna try
and subdue them and you subdue them in
the only way you know how and it results
in seriously hurting them I'm like well
I'm not gonna blame the victims right
like if you if the only method you have
is what you have
and you try like I'm not it's not your
fault you know I I don't know I think
it's ridiculous
have you have you ever seen like
anything like this happen where it's
been a serious injury beyond the fact
like just beyond like you know you said
earlier there they're out and they're up
again have you seen it ever take longer
than that like where they're out and
they're really messed up for like you
know they have serious brain damage Etc
no I've never seen that usually when
they're out and go unconscious you know
like 10 20 seconds later they'll wake up
and they'll be completely fine so that's
what tells me there's definitely some
foul play going on and the guy had some
things in his system that we don't know
about and we need to get some more facts
about it before we start pointing the
fingers right
all right leguma says as Neo maoists the
woke want us to be scared not to join
their cultural revolutionary anarch of
tyranny hence everyone there is blamed
for not stopping the Marine nearly BLM
drag queen's antifa and all are engaged
in the sacred dismantling of the unjust
Society it is neo-maoism that is yeah
observation yeah because it concludes
that whole uh the struggle sessions you
know yep yeah they're struggling my girl
Taylor Swift today yes what were they
really yeah what happened she's dating
some dude that made bad jokes in the the
Swift the Lefty swifties are all like
Taylor you can I'm like shut up and
leave Taylor alone Lefty swifties oh my
God which is probably like nice but she
hates Trump doesn't she she had a viral
video where she was like but it's never
you know it's never enough
you know it's never enough what do you
mean it's never enough no I'm saying she
had a video from a long time ago where
she was saying that she wanted to speak
out against Trump or something like that
no I know but I'm saying or it kind of
sounded like she was trying to speak up
in in favor of like you can be on the
left but if they find one little thing
that's out of whack if you're not
perfectly obedient to the cause you're
the devil you're you're an evil evil
person she said something like he might
lose but at least I can say I tried did
she really yeah and it implied like she
wanted to speak up in support of trump
wow I've heard that yeah I don't know
you got to pull up the video because I'm
like it seems like people are like
people were saying she hated Trump she
was anti-trump and conservatives will
still support her and ignore this but
then she said something like
he could still lose but at least I tried
or something like that I'm like it
sounds like she's saying she wants to
speak up to support him and that if he
loses well at least he tried to get him
elected right yeah you're looking it up
well here's the thing the first article
I found was Taylor Swift is 100 right
about Donald Trump from CNN
she was against uh 2018.
it was it was a viral clip that was
going around I'm just curious what like
insightful public policy prescriptions
uh Taylor Swift had about what Donald
Trump was doing in the Oval Office so I
want to read through this Gabriel Lopez
says crime opened borders and inflation
aren't problems that progressives are
trying to solve but weapons they are
wielding Aaron McIntyre so that's right
at the beginning of this article when
Pop Mega star Taylor Swift criticized
GOP candidates in her home state of
Tennessee and urged people to vote for
their Democratic opponents Donald Trump
responded that he now liked Taylor
Swift's music quote about 25 less
75 I still do enjoy it I really do if
he's like
but when were you saying you know you
need to calm down I really enjoy it
quite frankly uh Our Song is the
slabbing screen door I do feel that way
haha
Cosmic surgeon says I shared Tim's tweet
on patriots.win and it's been been hot
all day currently 1606 upvotes thanks
Tim thanks well it was kind of a
derivative of that um that John die joke
I think his name is is it John I hope
I'm not getting his name is John okay
where he said if lizzo is so beautiful
how come women get offended when I say
you look like lizzo and then I tweeted
start complimenting liberal women by
saying they look like Dylan Mulvaney or
lizzo well there's a thing I saw I saw
this forever ago on Twitter and it was
killing me this guy was saying I tell
left-wing women on Twitter I just DM
them and say them that they're like very
a very beautiful trans woman and they
get upset why would they get upset right
like the the thing is the thing is we'd
be fine with it but it's a compliment
the lizzo joke hits the nail on that
with the hammer yeah they're lying yeah
they're they're doing this thing where
they're like it's like a Trope from old
movies where they're like Oh no you're
pretty no I'm ugly no you're pretty and
like they don't really think it they're
just saying these things yeah it feels
like a Monty Python bit almost all right
does so uh we did talk about this but
Paul uh tascalo says ask Colby if he's
aware that under certain state laws his
hands are considered deadly weapons as a
trained professional fighter does that
make you worry about protecting yourself
yeah definitely that's that's why I kind
of keep myself out of a lot of
situations you know I don't go to bars I
don't I don't go to a lot of public
places I kind of I live a very sheltered
life you know I go to the gym and I go
home and you know I I don't really
engage in going out in public too much
because I already know people are going
to try and get a reaction out of me
because they know I'm a professional
fighter and they know if I touch them
they can just sue me so yeah I never put
myself in those positions try and try
and get some fame or something out of it
some PR stunt some fame or crazy soon
because it's so they know we're lethal
weapons and if we touch them you know
they know we make good money so they
could just come after us there's this
old viral video from like 20 years ago
where there's a professional fighter
backing away with his hands up and these
like four guys are like yelling at him
and waving their fingers and then they
run at them and then it just puts his
fists up and he goes one two three four
and then he just keep as he's backing
away and they're charging him and they
all just go down and then he puts his
hands up like nah like stop dude it was
an awesome awesome video people might
know which one I'm talking about it's
funny to watch like the dude who knows
how to fight is begging you not to fight
him yep
you don't want to go there man yeah all
right I'll grab something yeah if people
realize exactly how tiring getting into
fights like after two two rounds of
rolling I'm done I'm I'm maybe I'm my
cardio is bad and and like I said I'm a
white belt so it's not like I'm some
kind of fighter or anything but man that
stuff just Tuckers you right now Mark
Zuckerberg could beat you up absolutely
you saw that yeah that's brutal yeah he
won he didn't he win like a gold or
something yeah
there's two ways I think he won well
there's three ways the most likely way
is that as he was grabbing them to throw
him he had a wad of cash in his hand
that he was putting into their hands
the second is that he is you know an
Android and so he just won't grab them
and they're like uh I can't move and the
third was he trained really really hard
and then you know yeah I don't think so
the last one seems ridiculous the thing
is like when you're loaded like that and
you actually have that kind of time like
I get why like Zuckerberg is you know
spending the time doing Jiu Jitsu and
why like
um what's his name Bezos is like all
jacked now like you got no excuse to be
out of shape and be a you know a
doughboy get out and do something you
got all the money in the world yeah no I
I I I do think that Zuckerberg probably
trained and probably won like we're not
we're not acting like he entered the the
like UFC or something and and beat the
best in the world wouldn't that be
hilarious though if you play the UFC off
he's like you guys gotta let me win oh
he's been talking about it with him man
he's been like buying out like he'll go
to UFC events and he'll buy out like the
crowd and like show and he's trying to
get it like on metaverse or something no
way
no way I can't even like do you you
think can you imagine what metaverse
fights would be like no we should get
you know how they do those celebrity
fights like they do the YouTuber boxing
matches but then uh what about like
Logan Paul versus Mark Zuckerberg
oh my gosh what about just everyone
who's been banned and Mark Zuckerberg
he's just trying to get into a ring with
everyone he's bad from Facebook
in the ring together oh like the the the
story about Zuckerberg winning that
fight I I'm not I don't think it was a
super high level five I think it was
like a very low level fight he probably
won well it wasn't a fight yeah right
Jujitsu man what happened getting
punched in the face in a fight and doing
some rolling in Jiu Jitsu and getting a
point
his younger sister called him a mean
name and then he you know
I don't know though I think Mark
Zuckerberg could probably beat you up
Sheamus Mark Zuckerberg you think
Zuckerberg and I yeah
Tim I don't even know if I can do this
show anymore I'm trying to be reasonable
I'm trying to be reasonable though
because like I don't train fighting and
neither do you but Phil does and
obviously pointed at me and not yourself
no but what I'm saying is like
to be fair I think it's it's reasonable
to argue that a person who is on camera
training in any kind of like I'm gonna
give him credit that he he probably I
just don't know if I just don't know if
I think Mark Zuckerberg could beat me up
I just don't know if I believe that he's
actually trained I think so like I'm not
he's the expert Tim yeah here's the
physical training I have I have running
and jumping off of things I can climb
really well from skating I can like
probably do parkour and stuff so that
gives me some advantage in a fight but
if Zuckerberg's been training and
grappling I think he probably I wouldn't
know what to do I don't have that
training you know I'm doomed I got a sub
second draw though that's it I don't
think it's been trained I think it's a
photo op I think he's just trying to
pull people like oh I'm this tough guy
you know because everybody knows he's a
little nerd he ain't tough there's
nothing tough about him man he's afraid
of shadows out there what about Bezos
though you see the picture of him he's
like all like working out Juiced up on
steroids everybody knows you can't have
that type of transformation it's obvious
it's not funny it's facts though yeah
100 you know put some testosterone
hghanivar and all the other drugs you
know the cocktail of drugs that people
are doing with steroids these days
here's a question then so you were
saying like Bezos you just got he got
too big too fast based um how how long
did I I guess I didn't pay attention to
that transformation how quickly did this
guy get jacked I don't know within like
a couple months
yeah yeah like the same amount of time
it took him to make like a billion
dollars
let's grab something he literally just
bought a guy's muscles and implanted
them into his body I mean dude science
people are doing that yeah or he's just
working on the new genetic modification
technology there's a uh Ford Fischer was
tweeting about a documentary he did
where people are injecting themselves
with a gene therapy an experimental gene
therapy outside of us jurisdiction I
don't know the full details but you guys
can check it out Ford Fisher on Twitter
he's got a YouTube channel too and he
was it's basically what these people do
is they inject themselves I'm probably
getting it wrong but it does something
to deactivate fat production and
increase muscle production there's
something about the mechanism by which
we switch between fat production and
muscle production causes some kind of
Aging it's very simple way of putting
interesting and one guy's basically
saying I don't expect to starve anytime
soon in modern society so I'd rather
have proper muscle regeneration which
makes you live longer and so they're
injecting themselves with this this gene
therapy to
extend their lives and they've been
doing it for a while apparently what
you're describing sounds like Trend
alone I mean it's like just like you
know like if you're take if it if it
suppresses uh fat and and helps build
muscle that just that sounds like gear
yeah I'm gonna go to a doctor here
pretty soon because I'm in my 40s I'm
gonna see if I can get some uh
testosterone replacement or whatever
I think we can all agree that Bill Gates
has no excuse anymore for looking the
way he does he does yeah dude it'll be
the greatest thing if we got like Bezos
Zuckerberg Gates Dorsey who else can we
get let's get Soros in there why is too
old though I guess I guess Bill Gates is
too yeah but I think it's funny how Bill
Gates is telling everybody how unhealthy
they are and he's just like very out of
shape and yeah yeah it's really wild
actually
what do we got here John Starling says
after a 15-hour day welding watching Tim
cash for the next ww champ uh and uh
favorite UFC fighter making my night
uh hello from North Carolina Colby
shout out shout out to my man from North
Carolina man much love and respect and
uh you know God bless you
Vindicated Dasha says you say get out of
the Cities but I'm the caretaker of a 90
year old grandparent that refuses to
leave and it keeps us stuck no matter
how much we want to leave I hear you and
Another good argument made to me was
someone said that they got divorced
through no choice of their own and they
can't leave their kids in the city they
they need to be an influence for their
kids they can't leave they can't leave
and I'm like yeah that's true like I
would never Advocate someone abandon
their children if they were stuck there
because of laws just me makes a really
hard situation yeah
that's rough true it's true you know I
mean if you can get out but it's not
like the people around this table here
are like unaware that people have you
know serious problems in their life and
serious issues with with just picking up
and leaving you know yeah
Leon says 1930s Germany publicly declare
support or else
that's what it was like right yeah true
man that's crazy
let's grab some more Super chats
John medeski says Colby these dudes
never even been punched in the face
before do your thing be like water my
friend
he came here to fight all of us yeah I
only beat up crybaby Libs
I don't punch conservatives in the face
especially these are some of the biggest
fighters in the world right here they're
fighting up against the establishment of
fighting you know all the all the deck
that's stacked against them you know so
yeah and I'm gonna push back real
Fighters for real ready to rumble says
Tim has never been in a fight his whole
life he has ran away I have been in many
fights
um I wouldn't say I've been in large
amounts of fights but I appeared on
Tucker Carlson tonight specifically
because when I was in Boston and an
antifa guy started swinging at me I I
tightened my muscles leaned in and said
do it and I filmed him as he kept trying
to swing at me and make me Flinch and so
they asked me to come on and talk about
it and I was like look man if this
antifa guy while I'm live streaming
wants to hit me hit me like for it's not
the end of the world I'm not gonna die
I'm not gonna go to the hospital I'll be
sore maybe depending on what and then
I'll have on camera this guy attacking
me unprovoked so make my day
yeah I I like people people rag on me
because there's a video where a guy
pulls my hat off and then I immedly turn
around and threaten and knock all of his
teeth out and I'm like you're making fun
of me because I got really angry and
overreacted I'm like if there was no
police there probably got into a fight
so like dude don't don't put like you
shouldn't put your hands on people like
don't yeah don't grab people and try
picking fights like that don't do that
I was in Boston and I had this antifa
guy swinging at me and then stopping
just short of the camera and then
swatting at me and I'm standing there
and then I don't even know how long
after another guy walks up and grabs my
hat and then and I'm surrounded by cops
and I'm just like already really angry
and wanting to feel some kind of
emotional satisfaction because I know I
can't hit an antifa guy I'm not gonna
get in a fight while I'm on the ground
and this guy's trying to provoke me and
then some dude puts his hands on me and
now I'm just like
I was triggered I was mad triggered and
I'm like surrounded by cops and I'm just
like I'm not gonna overreact like I I
can't do anything that's what they want
yeah I'm like they want a reaction well
they yeah it's called mid-level violence
they it's like when you know not I'm not
touching you I'm not touching you I'm
not touching you the point of that is to
get a reaction out of you and and there
are things that they do that still
counts as assault when they do it you
know yeah that should be a salt touch
someone invading their personal privacy
like look at this but you have
everything to lose you know you have an
Empire these guys are nobodies and they
have nothing to lose so they have
everything to gain
yep all right we'll grab some more Super
chats
amenthy says I would give up my right to
vote if it meant Ben Crump was disbarred
and we never heard from him again but
that would be like you voting to make it
so that he's disbarred and that's like a
good that's a good vote
that's a great vote very good trade
all right self-made woman says to cover
all bases does Citibank Karen have a
time stamp for the bike according to the
New York Post they reviewed the time
spent a time stamp and confirmed it was
from the moment yeah people one minute
before the video is when she took the
bike out yeah and also uh people in chat
because people are asking why did they
blur the time stamp out people in chat
were saying it's so that random people
on the internet don't know when she gets
off shift oh what her schedule is yeah
and that's why the New York Post said
they confirmed it without revealing the
time they don't want to people go find
her job make sense
yep yeah see a better a better feature
says on the receipt why is the time
stamp the only thing blacked out did she
go back after the fact and rent the bike
in order to fake it what legit reason is
there to redact the time stamp she's
leaving work and Pregnant and people are
threatening her so they don't want to
reveal what her shifts are whatever but
I mean
everybody still knows where she works
yeah
this is a crazy world remember remember
this all I remember the first canceling
do you remember the first canceling
the woman on Twitter was flying
something oh my gosh and she tweeted a
joke about AIDS and then and then while
she's in the air with no internet the
tweets going viral like crazy and when
she lands she finds out everyone in the
world hates her she's fired from her job
and she had no idea why and she was
making a woke joke she said something
like
she won't happen to me because I'm white
or something she said yeah like it's
unless you hope she doesn't get AIDS but
it won't happen because she's white and
she was trying to make a left-wing joke
about how about white privilege about
how right they they seems unaffected and
they're not part of the impoverished
communities it did not matter the left
doesn't have humor so it's like nope
that was just racist and wake up call
for this lady
well it was a wake-up call for the world
because that was kind of the first time
that it happened Yeah Ashley says the
bike Karen is definitely a Democrat she
said you're hurting my fetus fetus us
conservative women call it what it is a
baby even when we are growing them I
noticed that too
she said you're hurting my fetus
so weird like this is the this is the
problem
if these people intentionally want these
things to happen who are we to tell them
they should not have them like you know
if you tell me you want lower taxes you
know Colby and then you vote for it and
then you come back later and say you got
lower taxes but congratulations if a
liberal in the city says I want violent
criminals out on the street and then the
final criminal attacks them am I going
to be like oh no I'm not going to go to
a guy who voted for lower taxes and be
like oh you poor man you got lower taxes
I'm like will you voted for it
I don't know what else to say man like
but why see like that's what we're doing
we're assuming to that they need our
sympathy if if I don't I don't know who
she voted for but there's a fair point
about her calling it a fetus if she did
vote for it I mean I I we should be
saying congratulations to congrats yeah
yeah like I'm happy for you that you got
what you what you wanted you know true
me I got uh uh I got uh some chickens
chickens yeah yeah I wanted those
chickens they they created more of
themselves I'm very happy that I have
them you wanted violent criminals to be
released on the street they are now and
you got that we're all living our best
lives yeah congratulations but now
they're raising money off it too see
this is the thing I'm concerned about
the Daniel Penny thing I get this is a
guy who people are cheering for he's a
hero he's a Marine he's trying to stop
someone who's very very violent this
woman I don't know for sure yet but I am
concerned about someone being a lib who
votes for these policies gets victimized
by them and then comes to us and says
now give us money like that's where I'm
like yeah fishy I don't want to be doing
that I don't want to fall for that
Tom pants says no stop with this do
whatever you want but don't go after
kids and don't break laws that's why we
are where we are today objective
morality and enforcement thereof is
required to preserve a stable culture
yeah I agree mostly
um I've talked about this quite a bit
but it doesn't matter what we think the
principles are or aren't because uh we
have her on moral lines uh and and
trying to simplify the idea
both the left and the right will argue
that parents have a right to choose
what's best for their kids
except when it comes to like this this
trans kids thing splits it where the
left says the government has no right to
tell me what to do with my children if
they're aborting them but the government
has a right to intervene to take a child
from his parents if the child is trans
so it's like the principle is irrelevant
you know what I mean there's no the
morality there is strictly subjective
morality of leftist tribal groups a baby
in the womb has no right to life and the
government can't intervene but a child
outside the womb who wants to get
sterilized The Government Can seize and
then without the parents knowledge
sterilize so like you can't
yeah it's almost like they just hate
innocent life or something
you know I think they want there to be
less people
as well that's also true yeah they well
it's interesting because
they don't profess to believe in
innocence but on a deeper level I think
they do they don't believe it children
yeah they hate it they want the the
whole project of the left that the LGBT
stuff in in schools and stuff is
essentially just to destroy the
innocence of children that is really
what and this is I'm an agnostic so like
me and Sheamus aren't like James is the
religious guys it's not like I'm like
pumping out like some kind of you know
religious take but do it they're still
evil like
so all right if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com because we gotta we got a
fun members only show our guest for
tomorrow morning canceled and you're
going to want to hear why but we're not
going to say on YouTube literally not
allowed to I think you are but it's
family I'm Gonna Keep It family friendly
fair enough talking about medical
procedures and stuff we'll keep it for
the fam for the members only uh
uncensored so again at timcast.com smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me personally at timcast
Colby do you want to shout anything out
uh you know just shout out to all the
Patriots out there holding down the line
man we you know we're getting stripped
of our freedoms every day so you know
they're they're pushing the line farther
and farther they're coming for our
children they're coming for all our our
rights as Citizens so you know shout out
to all the Patriots out there holding
the line right on awesome man thank you
um for for coming on on everything my
name is Jameis Coughlin I'd like to
shout out Freedom Tunes uh I make
cartoons we released one today it was
referenced in the super chats that Tim
was reading earlier so I really think
you guys will enjoy it if you go over
there and watch it thank you very much
freedomtunes youtube.com Freedom Tunes
I am filibonti I am Phil that remains on
Twitter I am Phil that remains official
on Instagram the band is All That
Remains we are available you can check
us out on Spotify uh Apple music and uh
Pandora probably YouTube as well
I am surge.com I'm watching Tim and
Sheamus throw paper airplanes each other
because that's how he missed when we
keep it here yeah
uh yeah follow me on Twitter let's argue
you know how it goes
you all over at timcast.com uh in a few
minutes thanks for hanging out